Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, jetzt seid ihr alle schon am Start.
Was du Rad fahrst?
Jetzt?
Heute?
Nee.
Was kommt denn da drauf?
Außerdem regnet es gerade.
Da habe ich keinen Bock.
Hey Max, ich überlege mir den Job zu wechseln vom Systemhaus zur Bank.
in deinen Gedanken, dass die Bank
wahrscheinlich deutlich besser bezahlt.
Also aus dem
Gesichtspunkt ist es wahrscheinlich eine gute Idee.
Gestern,
nee, gestern war ich nicht Fahrradfahren, gestern war ich
eine Stunde Joggen.
Ich habe gemerkt, ich meine, ich habe jetzt ja schon eine ganze
mindestens zwei Monate
so wie gar nichts mehr gemacht
und ich habe gemerkt, es lässt
halt nach.
Ich bin extra ohne Uhr gerannt,
also ohne Fitnessuhr, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
einfach mal so, wie es sich gut anfühlt, rennen.
Aber ich habe noch nicht mal
die ganze Runde gepackt. Die ganze Runde
sind 7,5 Kilometer.
Ich habe, weiß ich nicht, 5,5
oder so gepackt. Und da habe ich mir gedacht,
jetzt reicht es aber auch echt mal.
Ich hätte mich sicherlich noch irgendwie durchbeißen
können, wenn ich es übertrieben hätte.
Aber
muss ja bei der ersten Runde nach 2,5
oder 3 Monaten, keine Ahnung,
muss ja nicht übertreiben.
Ich hatte schon das Gefühl, ich bin langsam gelaufen,
Aber ohne Uhr weiß man das nicht so genau. Da kommt es einem manchmal viel langsamer vor, als man eigentlich ist.
Was du verdienst mehr dort als... Ja gut, dann ist die Frage, ob du irgendwelche anderen Vorteile für dich siehst.
Sei es jetzt irgendwie bessere Arbeitsbedingungen, mehr Aufstiegschancen, was du vorhast, vielleicht in Zukunft, keine Ahnung.
Das kann ja jetzt so, so ohne irgendwelche Sachen kann man das ja nicht sagen.
Hängt halt von den jeweiligen Arbeitgebern ab.
Also Banken hat halt echt den Vorteil, es ist in der Regel, sagen wir mal, recht entspannt.
Es ist nicht so, dass bei uns nichts los ist oder so.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so wie damals, wo ich noch beim Internetprovider da meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
danach auch da gearbeitet habe.
Da war es viel chaotischer und schlechter organisiert und deswegen stressig.
also das bin ich das finde ich hierbei wo ich meine ich bin ja nicht mal bei einer bank ich
bin jetzt bei einer versicherung aber das ist so groß unterschied ist es jetzt an hat ja also
das ist schon das schon ganz nice und die jobs da sind halt auch wenn einem das wenn
das wichtig ist sehr sicher also zumindest so wie ich das erlebt habe
Ansonsten ist halt die Frage, was
was versprichst du dir von?
Du musst ja schon irgendwas überlegt haben
wenn du dir hier überlegst
den Job zu wechseln, also irgendeinen Grund muss es ja geben
vielleicht bist du ja bei deinem alten Arbeitgeber nicht mehr happy
weil dir, keine Ahnung, der Chef
auf den Keks geht, die Arbeit nicht mehr gefällt
die Leute, die auf den Sack gehen, keine Ahnung, gibt's ja alles mögliche
dann
ist es vielleicht besser
zu wechseln. Also das kann man so
einfach so aus dem
Kame kann ich da jetzt ja nichts zu sagen.
Du kannst dich technisch, ja dann.
Und ganz ehrlich,
vielleicht hast du ja auch die Chance,
weil ich weiß, dass sie sowohl
bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber als auch
bei meinem neuen suchen die teilweise händeringend
Leute und finden keinen. Wir sind ja beide,
sagen wir mal, im Finanzsektor.
Jetzt Finanzdienstleistungssektor.
Und
da hat man auch ganz gute
ganz gute
Verhandlungsmöglichkeiten
bevor man den
Vertrag unterschreibt.
Also vielleicht kannst du
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr raushandeln.
Weil eins muss man ja sagen,
denen fehlt es ja nicht am Geld.
Beverly Hills Holzkopf,
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Ja.
Also ich habe noch keinen erlebt.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Führungskräfte dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite, viel besser als beim alten Arbeitgeber.
Ich meine, das kann man jetzt nicht auf den Einzelfall runterbrechen.
Wir hatten da durchaus auch gescheite Führungskräfte, ja.
Aber so im Durchschnitt würde ich schon sagen,
Winecodes,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Würde ich schon sagen, dass dort, wo ich jetzt bin,
die Führungskräfte besser ausgebildet sind
und auch nur die Leute
Führungskräfte werden, die
sich irgendwie dafür eignen und das auch
machen wollen und dann auch schon ein bisschen Vorkenntnisse
haben in der Richtung. Also,
bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber war das so,
ich mach mal kurz meine 4M an, um Package-Updates
zu installieren. Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
war das so, also bei meinem letzten,
da wurde alles Führungskraft, was bei 3
nicht auf dem baum ist glücklicherweise war ich immer bei drei auf dem baum weil
da hätte ich wirklich keinen bock drauf gehabt aber da wurden dann auch für die
leute verheizt ja also ich habe da schon ein paar gesehen die sind dann wieder
quasi zurückgetreten von dieser position oder sogar ganz ganz weg vom unternehmen
und sowas weil weil das nichts für die war und beim neuen arbeitgeber ist das
so wenn du davor hast so was zu machen da kannst du das anmelden und dann
machst auch schon ein paar kurse und wir es darauf vorbereitet also wirst nicht so ins kalte wasser
geschmissen was viel besser ist und dementsprechend machen das eigentlich auch nur leute die das
machen wollen und die das auch irgendwo können ja das ist viel besser
Habe ich ihn hier noch für Zeug auf?
Dustin, danke für den Sub.
Ach, hier von gestern.
Ich muss ja sagen, wir haben ja gestern ein bisschen Java programmiert.
Das hat mega Bock gemacht.
Ich glaube, das liegt jetzt weniger an Java selbst.
Also ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt, was ich von der Sprache gesehen hätte, sagen würde, es ist die beste Sprache ever.
Sondern generell macht halt neue Sachen lernen.
Irgendwie Bock, ja.
Hast du schon gehört, was aus meiner Verfassungsbeschwerde geworden ist?
Ne, das habe ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt.
Ne, was ist...
Weiß ich nicht. Ne, erzähl.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Updates nebenbei.
Das klingt als wäre es mit Sinn und Verstand, wo gibt es denn sowas?
Ja, das wundert mich auch immer wieder, dass da einiges mit Sinn und Verstand passiert.
Zum Beispiel, stellt euch mal vor, beim jetzigen Arbeitgeber ist es so, die bilden ja auch aus, Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
und die haben es jetzt tatsächlich geschafft,
dass wir im Team einen Azubi kriegen,
der dann auch bei uns bleibt,
wenn er fertig ist
und die alten Leute noch so lange da sind,
dass sie ihn einarbeiten können
mit den Sachen, die er dann machen soll.
Das wirkt so durchdacht,
das ist jetzt mal beim alten Arbeitgeber nicht gegeben.
Aber du musst mir das jetzt nochmal kurz erzählen.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch gelesen auf Twitter.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Vielleicht habe ich es irgendwie geistig ein bisschen verdrängt.
Ne, ne, das geht schon hier.
Man sieht den Link, ja.
Ach, du hast...
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
An die eigentliche Sache kann ich mich natürlich noch erinnern.
Das war die Geschichte mit einem MySQL-Passwort
Passwort im Source Code, wo man sich übers Internet quasi hin verbinden konnte
Wo sie dann gesagt haben ganz böse Hackerman Sachen am Start weil man
Das Programm in einem Hex Editor oder so geöffnet hat ja
glaube ich habe es halbwegs richtig wiedergegeben
Wo sie dann bei dir gesagt haben hier das ist quasi
Illegales
Ja oder wie auch immer strafrechtlich relevantes gehackt gewesen
Zeit mal her bundesverfassungsgericht lehnt beschwerde im fall modern solutions ab
Das ist ja top aktuell
Ja die sind richtig dumm ganz ehrlich ich kann es auch überhaupt nicht verstehen
Dass sie damals so ein fass aufgemacht haben weil wenn man eins gelernt hat im internet
dann ist es, umso mehr man über solche negativen Sachen redet, umso bekannter wird es.
Und das hat denen wahrscheinlich unterm Strich nichts gebracht.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht lehnt es ab, mehr Klarheit in den Umgang mit dem Hackerparagrafen zu bringen.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Das wäre in der Tat nicht verkehrt.
Alles schon ein bisschen schwammig ist.
ja klar also zumindest den namen hat jetzt fast jeder in dem bereich schon mal irgendwie gehört
und verbindet damit nichts positives genau also deswegen ich meine ich werde wahrscheinlich in
fünf jahren oder so jetzt nicht mehr permanent präsent im kopf haben aber wenn ich in fünf
jahren mal irgendwo modern solutions lese oder gehen wir mal von aus kommt er auf der arbeit
öfters mal vor, dass irgendwelche Dienstleister gesucht werden für
whatever, irgendwas. Und da würde mal der Name Modern Solutions
aufploppen. Da würde mir auch in 5 Jahren noch einfallen, sag mal,
da war doch irgendwas.
Okay, lass uns kurz lesen hier.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die Verfassungsstelle des Modern Solutions
prozess angeklagten IT-Experten ohne Begründung abgelehnt. Das ist natürlich doof. In einer
Entscheidung vom 15. September, die heise online vorliegt, heißt es, dass drei Richter und Richterinnen
des Gerichts einstimmig beschlossen haben, die Verfassungssprache nicht zur Entscheidung
angenommen wird. Okay, oh gut, die müssten das ja anscheinend nicht begründen, was aber doof ist.
Das hätte mich jetzt mal interessiert.
Vielleicht habe ich einfach keinen Bock.
Damit hat der Fall Modern Solutions seit Juni 2020...
Alle deutschen Gerichtsinstanzen vom Amtsgericht bis hin zum Bundesverfassungsgericht durchlaufen.
Ja, dann ist Schluss.
Das ist schon sätge irgendwie.
Dass es nicht mal eine Begründung für gibt.
Ja, Leute, merkt euch alle Modern Solutions.
Ja.
die geschichte des freiberuflichen IT-Experten
der eine Sicherheitslokale E-Crosser Firma entdeckte dafür statt einer Belohnung eine
Anzeige durch ach das war sogar mit Haus du alter krass das habe ich ja schon wieder vergessen
wegen so einem scheiß gibt es eine Hausdurchsuchung das muss man sich mal vorstellen na gut mittlerweile
gibt es ja auch sogar schon hausdurchsuchungen wenn ich habe schon wieder vergessen war da nicht
was mit mit mit mit mit dummkopf oder irgendwie sowas wo wurde wo die leute auch irgendwie in der
hausdurchsuchung bekommen haben die den harbert geflammt haben damals auf twitter zur kasseler
hausdurchsuche hausdurchsuchung sollte eigentlich wirklich für schwere für schwer kriminelle
irgendwie vorbehalten sein und nicht einfach mal random bei irgendwelchen
leuten weil du könnt man mal machen das ist so krass
es gibt da übrigens einen guten vortrag von irgendeinem ccc kongress wie man
sich verhalten sollte bei hausdurchsuchungen
Aber das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
7, 8 Jahre.
Warst du schon mal auf dem Kongress?
Nee, war ich noch nie.
Und du musst dir vorstellen, als Selbstständiger ohne Gerät.
Ja, es ist ja nochmal.
Also das ist super krass eigentlich.
Da kriegst du ja schon fast psychische Schäden danach.
Weil du dir permanent Gedanken machst.
Was ist, wenn mal wieder hier die Polizei klingelt?
Das stelle ich mir enorm belastend vor.
Also nicht nur.
Nicht eher.
also ja egal dass ich wieder sage ich jetzt nichts dazu hier beim arzt ist das
das ja genau vor sechs jahren ja schade nicht mal geguckt zu haben ich denke die
meisten von uns werden nie eine hausdurchsuchung bekommen
ich hatte schon mal aus durchsuchung bzw wo ich gar kann ich an der stelle
vielleicht kann man mal erzählen nicht ich das ist falsch ich hatte keine haus
durchsuchung es gab damals bei meiner mutter nach hausdurchsuchung lesen wir
lesen das wo habe ich jetzt den artikel hier offen weil wegen meinem vater das
habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt mein vater hat ja sagen wir mal deutlich zu
viel steuern bezahlt der war ja der war ja sogar ein untersuchungshaft wegen steuerhinterziehung
und eines tages also meine mutter war ja schon getrennt von dem zur damaligen zeit aber trotzdem
war eines tages die polizei in der wohnung und hat bei uns damals dass da war ich noch klein
Ja, hat bei uns damals die Wohnung durchsucht, ob es irgendwelche Hinweise auf Steuerhinterziehung von meinem Vater gab.
Seitdem habe ich da so eine ganz besondere Beziehung zu sowas wie Hausdurchsuchungen.
Ich habe es damals nicht so richtig realisiert alles, aber es hat mich schon mitgenommen.
Man denkt an nichts Böses und dann Hausdurchsuchungen, obwohl man selbst nichts gemacht hat, muss man wohl sagen, ja.
Meine Mutter war in keinster Weise irgendwie drin verwickelt, war auch nicht in diesem Prozess beteiligt. Ich schon mal gar nicht mit, keine Ahnung wie alt ich da war, 6, 7 oder so.
Trotzdem auch Durchsuchungen damals. Besser gesagt Wohnungsdurchsuchungen. Aber die Geschichte vom Vater habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Okay, ähm...
Nicht wenige hatten sich zuletzt von der Verfassungsschrift eine Klärung der diversen Rechts- und Sicherheiten im Alltag von IT-Experten und Sicherheitsfreunden erhofft.
Ja, das wäre cool gewesen.
Die waren als DHL-Boten verkleidet.
Wieso das, wenn du rausguckst, dass du nicht gleich alle Computer ausschaltest?
Oder trägst du Zähne?
Ja, die Klärung ist, dass es keine Klärung gibt.
Stattdessen liefert die letztinste entscheidende Oberlandesgericht Köln nun die Ablehnung der Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Oder das Gegenteil.
Macht den Eckartparagraf von Dorthin Heikel wie nie, eine gefundene Sicherheitslücke ans Licht der Öffentlichkeit zu bringen.
Ja, das ist ziemlich traurig eigentlich.
Wenn man sich das mal überlegt, das bestärkt ja irgendwie sogar noch die Leute, die was Illegales vorhaben.
Ja, weil die interessieren sich dafür eh nicht.
Aber wenn einer, sagen wir mal, vielleicht ein bisschen schwankt, so nach dem Motto, ey, nutze ich das jetzt vielleicht für wirklich was Illegales?
Oder bin ich der Gute und melde das?
aber wenn das Melden mehr Probleme macht
oder
sagen wir mal so, nicht mehr Probleme
wenn das Melden mit Sicherheit
oder mit höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit Probleme macht
dann machen die Leute entweder gar nichts
oder sagen, ja gut, da kann man da auch
irgendwie Kapital drausschlagen, was natürlich bei weitem
nicht jeder macht, ja, aber es gibt ja Leute
die stehen so dazwischen, die sagen, ah, vielleicht
könnte man da was rausholen für sich, aber
vielleicht könnte man es auch melden, natürlich wenn
das Melden mehr Schmerzen verursacht
als das Nichtmelden, ist schon doof
Hier wird wahrscheinlich der Fall nochmal erklärt.
Chat, was?
So ein Deep Web Marketplace Boss haben sie auflegen lassen, indem sie eine Blondine in sein Tor haben kacheln lassen.
Der schreit raus, er lebt, hat er nicht gesperrt.
Das muss man eh nicht erlassen, da sind sie ja erfinderisch.
Das Passwort zu dieser Datenbank auf den Server war unverschlüsselt in einer ausführbaren Datei.
Genau.
Ja, krass.
Ja, blöd.
Boah, der Artikel geht ja mega lang noch.
Es ist tatsächlich echt sehr sad, dass das abgelehnt wurde.
Da kann man wahrscheinlich jetzt auch gar nichts mehr gegen machen, oder?
So Beschwerde gegen die Beschwerde oder so, Berufung gegen die Beschwerde, wird es wahrscheinlich nicht geben, weil höher als das Bundesverfassungsgericht geht es halt nicht mehr.
Wie hast du eigentlich die Anwaltskosten bezahlt?
Hast du das alles aus eigener Tasche bezahlt, weil das ist ja bestimmt nicht billig?
oder wurdest du da in irgendeiner Art und Weise
supported, wenn du das sagen darfst
also ich stelle mir das
schon ziemlich teuer vor
es gibt noch den europäischen
Gericht so für Menschenrechte, ja gut das
glaube ich, wenn sich da
echt nicht so für interessieren
Wir können uns ja ausgegeben im Anlass mal irgendwann auch mal das hier zusammen angucken.
Können wir uns irgendwann demnächst mal anschauen, dass ihr auch Bescheid wisst, wenn ihr mal eine Sicherheitslücke meldet.
Ein Vorschlag, wie man sich korrekt fällt, wenn man eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden hat, wäre nett.
Ganz ehrlich, nach diesem Kram muss man eigentlich fast schon sagen, das Sicherste ist, die einfach gar nicht zu melden.
Was halt auch kacke ist.
Aber mit solchen Urteilen, oder es ist ja kein Urteil, mit solchen Entscheidungen geht es dann eher in die Richtung.
Max, danke für den Sub.
Hype Subscription.
Also ich hab nur einmal eine Sicherheitslücke gemeldet bisher beim Hersteller.
Das war bei einem Kamerahersteller, wo man das Rootpasswort der Kamera einfach mit einem Curl rauskriegen konnte.
wo es sich aber vorstellt ip kamera mit rtsp stream web interface zum administrieren und
das habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal gezeigt irgendwann wie das ging und da
kannst du mit einem kölner fehlkost passwort von der kamera aus ist ja das habe ich habe
den gist denn den anliste ist auf github gemacht wo ich das alles rein geschrieben
habe und habe den den leuten nach vom hersteller habe ich das per mail
geschickt und das erste was war ich bin bei irgendeinem support typ gelandet der
meint ist alles kein problem installieren sie einfach das neueste
firmware update dann ist alles gut der hat überhaupt nicht verstanden was
ich geschrieben habe zumal das relativ sicher auch das neueste firmware update
war da habe ich sagen die leute karl root passwort komplett kamera offen und
dann hat jemand darauf geantwortet der hat verstanden um was es geht und sein
größtes seine größte sorge war dass ich den github ist public schalte hat gleich
gefragt hat geschrieben wir kümmern uns drum
firmware update wird bereitgestellt kann ein bisschen dauern aber ob ich nicht
ob ich jetzt nicht das jetzt gleich wieder löschen könnte von github das war
sein größtes problem ja dass ich die gist nicht public schalte die größte
sorge die gerade naja aber man muss ihnen also eins muss man dem aber zugute
halten die haben das tatsächlich gefixt hat ein
halbes jahr oder so gedauert und irgendwann habe ich eine mail geschrieben
es steht jetzt neue firmware update bereit machst du mal wieder was auf youtube ja mach ich
das habe ich gut bei meinem arbeitgeber habe ich auch schon was gemeldet zum beispiel habe
ich letztens rausgekriegt dass ein passwort geschützter video stream nicht passwortgeschützt
ist.
Wenn man die
URL weiß. Wenn man die richtige URL weiß.
Habe ich gemeldet.
Das ist aber auch schon wieder 14 oder
drei Wochen, 14 Tage oder drei Wochen her.
Ich habe noch nichts,
noch nichts gehört
von unseren Security-Leuten.
Da muss ich mal nächste
Woche, nächste Woche fragen.
was da los ist
hast du das mit dieser home automation firma aus skandinavien wird mit rossmann probleme
was was wir jetzt erzählt oder hast du irgendwie link gibt es ein link
bei heise oder irgendwie golem oder irgendeine news habe ich nicht gehört
hat ja wo ich nicht wach sein für den sub soll leute ich konnte sich alles
durch falls irgendwas übersehen habe sagt bescheid ich wollte auch package
updates machen gucken ob es jetbrains zeug gibt
übrigens mir hat das so viel bock gemacht ja war gebastelt gestern dass ich
sogar Offstream danach das Ganze nochmal
ordentlich gemacht habe bei mir in der VM.
Und ich habe sogar bei mir
so ein Cache eingebaut,
dass die API-Response nicht immer
hier gegen diese Test-API geht,
sondern quasi jede Response
gecached wird nochmal.
Das hat echt Bock gemacht. Ich glaube, das liegt
weniger an Java, sondern dass es einfach
manchmal Bock macht, neue Sachen zu lernen.
Letzte Woche in Frankfurt habe ich so gehofft, Stimme in der Bahn oder am Bahnhof zu hören.
Ja, die Chancen sind sehr gering.
Ich bin zwar auch jede Woche in Frankfurt am Hauptbahnhof, aber die Chancen, dass man sich da über den Weg läuft und ich gerade was sage, während du in Hörreichweite bist, sind doch recht gering.
Ne, mit Kotlin mache ich das nicht nochmal.
Weil es hat ja einen Sinn, warum ich den Java mache und nicht den Kotlin.
Wir haben mal rausgefunden, dass das Zeiterfassungssystem bei 90% der Mitarbeiter von außen und mit
Initialen erreichbar war.
Das hat mich nicht interessiert.
Das ist natürlich blöd gelaufen.
Flatter gelehrt.
Ja Dart ist eklig.
Ich habe auch mal vor
schon eine ganze Weile her,
da hatten wir hier auch irgendwann mal
was in Flutter ausprobiert.
Nicht Futter.
Haben wir was in Flutter ausprobiert.
Und ich muss sagen, Dart
hat mir auch überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Also es war erträglich,
aber wenn man sich das hier schon anguckt,
ich verstehe bis heute nicht, warum es Dart ist, ehrlich gesagt, bei Flutter.
Da muss wieder bei Google intern irgendwas gelaufen sein.
Die Flutter-Dart-Leute versus die Goal.
Warum ist es nicht Goal geworden? Ich verstehe das einfach nicht.
Die haben eine der weit verbreitetsten und mit beliebtesten Programmiersprachen bei sich im Haus
und dann machen sie Flutter mit Dart, was keine Sau interessiert, außerhalb von Flutter keine Bedeutung hat.
wahrscheinlich auch kaum Libraries oder sonst irgendwas
Gescheites für gibt.
Warum nicht Go? Das habe ich
bis heute nicht verstanden.
So.
Reboot.
Das hast du mit Java gemacht.
Aber mal gucken, was das ist.
Keine Description.
Ok, selbst wenn ich das lese, habe ich keine Ahnung, um was das geht, aber ich weiß nicht, was OSC ist.
Orovision Song Contest.
Wegen Browsers war das.
Gut, heute mit WebAssembly auch kein Problem mehr.
weiß gar nicht wie es mit go und web assembly aussieht gehen tut es bestimmt
open sound controller
was ist das das ist neu bei contacting des fernsehserver das ist neu wo wir es ist das
Irgendeine VMware-Geschichte, hä?
Ah, ich hab die VMware-Tools geupdatet.
Das könnte sein.
Was hat er denn?
Was?
Warum soll ich mich
per SSH da irgendwie... Hä?
Versteh ich nicht.
Irgendwas ist VMware-Zeug.
Aber war es nicht.
das ist das ist übrigens hintergrundbild ist gut ich muss was trinken und slackware
ich weiß noch irgendwas was lecker bestes außer an raid außer
außer bei android habe ich schon ewig nichts mehr von slackware gehört
Slackware ist für die Target Set Enjoyer. Gibt es keinen Package Manager, gibt es nur Target Sets.
Leon. So, dann gucken wir doch mal was bei GitHub so trendet diese Woche.
Dart ist ECMA, ein Ding so standardisiert, so wie JavaScript.
Na gut, du machst es auch nicht verbreiteter.
Ist da nicht eh nur 10x AI im Trend wahrscheinlich?
Es ist zu vermuten, ja.
Schauen wir mal.
trending weekly wir skippen wieder allen krempe marke down office documents zu markt
warum
Also wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen ich erstelle was in Markdown oder ich erstelle
was in Office, dann ist für mich die Auswahl relativ schnell klar.
Damit AI die besser verarbeiten kann.
Ach so, ah, 5 Hat.
Ja stimmt, man muss immer AI Gedulds im Hinterkopf haben, dann ergibt vieles Sinn.
Ja, das macht natürlich Sinn.
Clone a voice in 5 seconds.
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Wenn ich jetzt...
Ob man mal eine Voice klonen kann.
Keine Ahnung.
AI.
PowerShell-Trended?
Wie kommt es da jetzt dazu?
AI.
A.I.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Ist jetzt meine Güte.
Das wird es ja immer mehr.
Trennt ihr da noch was normales?
Irgendwas interessantes vielleicht zur Abwechslung mal?
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt mal was, was wir einmalig machen.
Wir gucken mal, was im Java-Umfeld so trendet.
Was ich ja gerade Java lerne.
So, mal gucken.
Leadcode für Java.
Ist das nicht ein YouTube-Client für Android?
Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Ja, oder?
Nutzt du auch IAC oder Ansible?
Naja, ich würde sagen Ansible ist IAC.
IAC heißt ja nur Infrastructure as Code.
Und wenn du dir Ansible anguckst, das sieht sehr Codemäßig aus.
Also wir benutzen Terraform und Ansible.
Bei uns ist es so, historisch gesehen, ist quasi fast alles, wo es um echte Hardware oder um On-Prem-VMs geht.
Die coolen Leute sagen ja nicht mehr im Rechenzentrum oder offline oder sonst was.
Die sagen immer alle nur On-Prem, weil es sich cooler anhört.
Das ist bei uns nahezu alles Ansible. Auch historisch ist das alles in Ansible entwickelt worden und da gibt es ganz viele fertige Module. Dafür ist in der Cloud das meiste Terraform.
wobei man halt auch sagen muss, Terraform und Ansible können sich auch ganz gut ergänzen
Terraform ist halt massive superior zu Ansible, was Infrastruktur-Provisionierung angeht
wenn es aber darum geht, irgendwas komplexeres auf beispielsweise einer Google VM zu konfigurieren
dann ist Ansible schon besser
glücklicherweise muss man bei den meisten VMs nach dem Aufbau gar nicht mehr so viel machen
und da tut es zur Not auch irgendein Cloud-Init
drei zeiler oder so
wo du sag ich auch von youtube premium ausgeschlossen warum
plain terraform
cdk finde ich jetzt persönlich nicht so toll cdk ist ja quasi noch mal scripting
drüber gelegt, wo dann unter der Haube
Terraform-Ressourcen erzeugt werden.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht so richtig.
Wenn man komplette Programmiersprachen,
eine ordentliche Programmiersprache verhelfen will,
könnte man auch Pulumi nehmen, aber ich muss
sagen, ich finde, plain Terraform
eigentlich erledigt den Job
ganz gut.
Zumal man jetzt irgendwie auch nicht denken darf, dass man mit CDK super krass dynamische
Sachen machen kann, weil unter der Haube fallen ja da immer noch statische Terraform-Ressourcen
raus.
Netzwerk habe ich mit Ensemble noch nicht gemacht.
Habe ich ewig nicht mitzutun.
Also das einzige, was ich mit dem Netzwerk zu tun habe, ist, ab und zu in unsere Firewall-Management-Webinterface zu gehen und dort irgendein Ticket zu beauftragen mit Freischaltung.
Das war's.
Also so richtig mit echter Netzwerkgeschichte.
ja mal bei google irgendein vpc oder irgendwas anlegen und das schon aber so richtig mit netzwerk
ist gut wie nix am hut crossplane ist mega nice crossplane würde ich auch gerne verwenden es
gibt bei uns ein testprojekt jetzt gerade mit crossplane kann terraform beziehungsweise open
tofo inzwischen ein for each ja konnte es doch schon die ganze zeit konnte schon kannst schon
lange terraform schleife machen ist halt hässliche syntax
das gibt es aber schon lange
Ist aber eklig.
Manchmal kommt man aber nicht drum herum.
Generell, ich bin kein Riesentheraform-Fan.
Es ist mit Abstand das verbreitetste und wahrscheinlich auch das...
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo das beste Tool für diese Sache, ja.
Aber es ist nicht so, als geht mir eine ab bei, wenn ich Theraform-Zeug programmieren muss.
Ich bin jetzt seit 1,5 Jahren Junior-Admin und habe mich in der Zeit weitgehend mit Palo
alto firewalls aja
Habe ich nur einmal was mit zu tun
Letztes laden wo ich gearbeitet habe die hatten palo alto firewalls und switching auseinandergesetzt
Ich hätte ziemlich interesse da weiter in die materie 1 allerdings habe ich interesse an pen testen ab wann wäre der richtige zeitpunkt sich dahingehend
Eine weiterbildung zu suchen du musst dir keine weiterbildung suchen du kannst dich also gut
Okay, vielleicht doch nicht so richtig, weil ich wollte eigentlich sagen, du musst dir keine richtige Weiterbildung suchen, guck einfach im Internet und lern, was du Bock hast. Da muss ich jetzt aber mal ein bisschen relativieren, weil ich mir gerade in der Beziehung nicht sicher bin, was es für Ressourcen dazu überhaupt gibt im Internet, ohne da wieder irgendwelche offiziellen Fortbildungen zu besuchen.
Weil gerade Netzwerkhersteller machen ja immer so ein bisschen Geheimnis drum.
Und bei denen ist ja auch die ganze Zertifizierungsmaschine so ein selbsterhaltendes Ökosystem aus Geldverdienen.
Deswegen weiß ich das gar nicht.
Aber generell mit Netzwerkgrundlagen und sowas, da gibt es mehr als genug im Internet.
Also der richtige Zeitpunkt ist eigentlich immer jetzt, wenn du dich fragst, wann der richtige Zeitpunkt ist.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie gut man in was werden kann, in viel kürzerer Zeit, als man so denkt.
Wäre aber immer unter der Voraussetzung, man interessiert sich persönlich dafür.
Weil was lernen, wenn man gegen sich selbst ankämpfen muss, weil man keinen Bock drauf hat, das geht meistens nicht gut.
Aber wenn man auch was Bock hat, geht es fast wie von alleine.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich wollte doch schon letztens mal wieder Packet Tracer installieren.
Geht das Package eigentlich wieder?
Immer noch nicht.
Das ist kaputt.
Das ist aber echt Sack, dass es kaputt ist.
Ecke Tracer ist beste.
Okay, hier, guckt mal.
Guide to Downloading and Installing.
Download Packet Tracer haben wir gemacht.
Was zum...
Okay, das ist Trick 17.
Moment, Moment, wir haben noch hier Downloads.
Äh.
Oh kann das sein, dass ich den Snapshot restored habe und das jetzt wieder weg ist?
Warten wir mal.
Warten wir nicht, wir haben uns doch so...
ist download packet tracer
auch in der optik hier sein opfer free
wir hatten das doch letzten schon mal wo ist es denn
genau ah mist ja gut ein minute mail war wieder beste ja
also sein ab
Wollen wir mal Germany, State, ja keine Ahnung.
Geil, Passwort Leak, dann nehmen wir doch was anderes würde ich sagen.
Da muss ich mir jetzt irgendwas ausdenken.
Brauche bestimmt Groß-Klein-Schreibung.
Ok, Copy-Paste.
Trade Account.
Save.
Ok, jaja.
wir accepten alles.
Alles accepted.
Ich will Packet Tracer
downloaden. Please, Cisco.
Wo ist es?
Wo ist der
Getting Started?
Okay, perfekt. Wo ist der Download
Knopf?
Wo ist da...
Lab Downloads, hier.
Packet Tracer, Ubuntu.
Ist halt sehr edgy, dass es das nur für Ubuntu gibt.
Haben wir nicht hier irgendwann ein Ubuntu vielleicht sogar?
Ne, ne?
Ist ja...
Okay, und jetzt...
Lass mal schauen, wie funzt das jetzt?
Download Dapp Files.
habe ich.
Try to install this packet. Copy the downloaded
file to
cache packet tracer.
Gibt's nicht.
Oh, ich spiele den falschen Ordner.
And name it so.
Okay, also
cp von downloads
packet tracer
soll so
heißen.
install ok packet tracer
moment das ist falsch es muss so heißen dass wir dafür pp gar zeug
packet tracer
CCNA ist nicht verkehrt.
Ja, hab auch eine CCNA gemacht vor Urzeiten.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass man EN machen muss, wenn man sich einloggt auf Cisco-Kisten.
No Shutdown für Ports.
Conf T.
Copy Running Start und so Zeug.
Ein paar Sachen weiß ich noch.
Aber ist nicht mal viel hängen geblieben.
Wir haben Packet Tracer am Start.
Sehr nice.
Would you like to run multi-user when applications...
Was?
Weiß gar nicht, was das von mir will.
No.
Sondern ich weiß, was das sein soll.
Packet Tracer, Leute.
Wenn ihr Netzwerksachen lernen wollt...
Was möchte der von mir?
Muss ich da Sign-In?
Ah, ich muss da Sign-In.
Sonst geht es nicht.
Äh.
Ja, Copy.
Sign-In.
Hä? Hat das mich jetzt eingeloggt?
Ich checke es gerade nicht.
Ne.
Hä?
was will er von mir
skills for all soll
warum gibt es da zwei knöpfe wenn das einenehmer funktioniert wir
successfully locked in ok nice packet tracer von also leute wenn ihr netzwerk basics lernen wollt
auch wenn das ding ein bisschen ein bisschen old school aussieht packet tracer ist das beste was
es gibt ich zeige euch noch mal eine sache woran man sieht dass es echt nah ist also mal angenommen
ihr habt ihr könnt ihr zwei pcs reinziehen so wir machen jetzt einfach mal zwei pcs verkabeln
die ganzen mitten wie ging das noch mal so ja mit zwei pcs mit wir machen mal
kein switch kein router oder sonst was da in der richtung so aber was man jetzt
machen kann ist man geht zum wir geben dem pc jetzt mal eine ip wo geht das
hier
geben dinge erzieher 12 168 keine ahnung 5.1 ach guck mal der auto kompliziert sogar
so oft ist der eine pc und der andere und zu unter andere kriegt also das ist alles nur simuliert
das ist alles nur simuliert muss man muss man denkt ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher ob
in den speichern knopf drücken muss dafür muss man nicht so und jetzt kann man sagen simulation
mode und wenn man jetzt hierhin geht auf den pc und sagt terminal öffnen das ist alles das ist
wie gesagt das ist alles nur eine simulation aber eine ziemlich gute und
kreis command prompt sondern jetzt sage ich ich bin auf dem pc ja sag jetzt ping
1 und 2 1 6 5.1 ich bin von dem pc den pc an
ich bin im simulations mod da kannst du jetzt hier sieht man jetzt schritt für
schritt was passiert auf auf auf dem netzwerk also man kann jetzt sagen okay
dieses device erzeugt jetzt erstmal ein ab request oder sowas kommt alle okay
kommt erst mal eine ping ping message so sieht das aus kann sie sogar den inhalt
vom paket angucken kannst sagen hier so sieht das aus von von den headern her
so hier unten drunter ist der ethernet frame also das ist wirklich exakt das was dieser pc
generieren würde um den zu bringen kannst den ganzen inhalts angucken von den paketen
kugler 2 sagt er okay wir generieren ein ethernet frame da drin ist dann ein ip package darin ist
ein ICMP-Request.
So, und das Ganze geht jetzt
Schritt für Schritt. Jetzt kann man weiter gucken.
Wie fängt es weiter? Jetzt wird es
dahin geschickt.
Und dann geht es hin und her.
Kann man sich angucken.
Und man kann dann auch so Sachen
irgendwie mal nachvollziehen, wie
geht ein Up-Request und sowas in der Richtung.
Quasi im Vorfeld erstmal gucken,
wie ist denn die MAC-Adresse von dem anderen.
Das haben wir jetzt verpasst, weil wir die schon
angeschlossen hatten ohne simulations modus also packe tracer ist wirklich beste für sowas
ja man kann sich spending tree angucken alles wirklich als packe tracer wenn wirklich basics
sich an beides geht geht weit über basics raus ja aber wer sich wirklich basics bis etwa an
zu netzwerksachen an ganz genau angucken will ohne scheiß packe tracer weil ihr braucht die
ganzen geräte nicht dafür und das schöne ist das ist natürlich sehr
cisco zentriert ihr könnt auch cisco geräte hier hinzufügen und da gibt es
dann auch wirklich so sachen wie das cisco ci
und hier en
chat was mache ich falsch kann ich jetzt nicht hier tippt der hat der boot noch
e n konf t mehr weiß ich nicht mehr no shutdown da muss er sport konfig oder so
machen ach keine ahnung mehr ja da hat man wirklich in cisco cli und
kann sein switch konfigurieren und wenn man im simulations modus wird man auch
ganz genau sehen wie hier irgendwas das kaufwerk wird was also richtig als
Packet Tracer ist wirklich das Beste.
Das wird, glaube ich, auch immer noch geupdatet.
Packet Tracer.
Ist gar nicht.
Sieht man das hier?
About.
Ach, ganz richtig.
Mal kalt.
2023, ja.
Das ist mega nice.
So.
Also, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wer das gefragt hat, aber Packet Tracer, wenn du was lernen willst.
Wenn du wirklich ganz genau wissen willst, wie es funktioniert.
Packet Tracer.
Ja, da ist es ja so, dass das wirklich echte Geräte, glaube ich, simuliert, ne?
Mit VMs unten drunter und sowas.
Ich fand Packet Tracer einfach von der Handhabung her einfacher.
Weil da weiß ich, das ist keine VM oder irgendwas.
Das ist alles im Packet Tracer simuliert.
Schau dir mal den Physical Mode an.
Ach, damit kann man sich auch wirklich ans Netzwerk attachen.
Ja.
er als beste updates haben wir gemacht die e mail adresse kann wieder löschen
dann würde ich sagen was eine stunde rum wir gucken mal dass unsere youtube so angucken
können ich wollte noch gucken was bei java so trendet spring boot trendet sehr gut xxl
Job China Chinesen Framework. Ida wusste gar nicht dass das in Java programmiert ist.
Nicht dass ich damit schon viel gemacht hätte, aber man kennt es vom Namen her. Weiß dass man
damit irgendwelche Sachen decompilen kann und Breakpoint setzen und hast du nicht gesehen.
Wobei Breakpoint setzen bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Das ist nicht meine Welt.
Kenn ich mich nicht gut mit aus.
So.
Ich mein, eins muss man den
Java-Sachen mal zugute halten.
Da trendet wenigstens nicht
nur irgendwelches
AI-Zeug.
Spring, okay.
Spring AI.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal gucken.
Was können wir uns auf YouTube angucken?
Der Internetboom in Deutschland.
DSL macht es möglich 2002.
Irgendwie habe ich da Bock drauf, mir das anzugucken.
Was hat denn die Oma da in der Hand?
Ist das ein NTBA?
Was ist das?
Ja, das ist ein NTBA, oder?
Meine Prediction, das wird schmerzhaft.
Ich glaube nicht.
Gucken wir mal.
Aber immerhin, damals haben sich die Omas noch dafür interessiert, hä?
Ja, das ist ein NTBA.
Oder was meint ihr?
Kennt ihr überhaupt noch...
Leute, wisst ihr überhaupt noch, was ein NTBA ist?
Weil ICN benutzt kein Mensch mehr.
Also, was heißt benutzen?
Kann man gar nicht mehr benutzen.
Chat, ihr wisst das noch?
Okay, weil
NTBA war damals für
ISDN quasi das,
wie nennt man so, das
Determinierungspunkt, keine Ahnung,
wie man das richtig nennt. Also dort hat man
das Kabel reingesteckt
vom Splitter.
Also es ging von der TAE-Dose in den
Splitter, vom Splitter an den NTBA
und an NTBA, ab dahinter wurde
dann quasi ISDN gesprochen
und man konnte da seine Telefone anschließen.
das war für die damalige zeit galt das als voll advanced du konntest bis zu wie viel ab bis zu
acht endgeräte konnte man glaube ich anschließen an isdn der ntb a selbst hat nur 22 stecker aber
man konnte glaube ich dahinter noch irgendwie so ein verteiler machen und dann glaube ich ging bis
zu acht endgeräten und man konnte bis zu zwei mann hatte bis zu zwei also man hatte zwei leitungen
und konnte dann quasi ins Internet und noch telefonieren dabei.
Das war richtig der heiße Scheiß.
Es war aber ein bisschen irgendwie an der zukünftigen Entwicklung vorbei.
Weil analoges Telefon, na gut, nee, kann man so nicht sagen,
analoges Telefon gibt es heute ja eigentlich auch nicht mehr.
Das gibt es hinter der Fritzbox noch, um Telefon anzuschließen.
Danach ist das alles IP-basiert.
und spätestens auf Provider-Seite.
Aber ISDN war ein bisschen irgendwie,
das war so an der damaligen Zeit ausgerichtet,
was weiß ich, welche, die faxen wollten und telefonieren gleichzeitig
oder irgendwie die Familie, dass die Kinder telefonieren können
und die Mutter kann auch die Freundin anrufen oder sowas.
Irgendwie war das alles nicht so,
aber das konnten die damals nicht wissen.
Man sieht ja auch daran, dass ISDN hat die Zeit nicht überlebt.
Aber so ganz normales Oldschool analoges Telefon, zumindest hinter der Fritzbox, gibt es immer noch.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ich will ja wissen, was die da treiben.
Dein Opa hat noch ein rein analoges Telefon.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch noch ein paar Sonderregelungen, wie man heute noch analoge Telefon an... Aber man muss dazu sagen, auch das Telefon von deinem Opa ist spätestens ab dem Verteiler in der Straße ist das IP basiert. Aber halt nicht mehr schon im Haus.
Ich glaube es gibt zwei Sonderregelungen
Wenn man wirklich nur einen nackigen Telefonanschluss bestellt
Dann bekommt man das immer noch
Also im Prinzip so wie ich gesagt habe
Man hat eine TAE Dose, kann dann analoges Telefon reinstecken
Aber dahinter ist es dann halt IP basiert
Oder ich glaube einen Sonderfall gibt es auch noch für Fahrstühle
Für alte Fahrstühle, dass der Fahrstuhlnotruf funktioniert
Ich glaube da gibt es auch noch eine Sonderregelung
wie man analogen Anschluss bekommen kann.
Ich glaube, ansonsten hast du Pech.
So.
Warum kicken die?
Was hat das mit...
Die Internetindustrie bläst unüberhörbar
zur Geschwindigkeitsoffensive.
T-Com sorgt für den Durchbruch.
Breitband für alle.
Kaum ein Computernutzer kommt zur Zeit an den Werbekampagnen von T-Com, AOL und Co. vorbei.
Nicht wenige sind jedoch von der Infoflut überfordert.
Moment, was? Was stand da?
Für Einsteiger, Umsteiger, Frauen. Da würdest du heute schon den übelsten Shitstorm kriegen.
Weil da für Einsteiger, Umsteiger, Frauen und Selyon draufsteht.
Da wäre Twitter heute auf den Barrikaden schon bei diesem Bild.
Ich begrüße Sie zu unserem Kurs Einstieg ins Internet.
Wir werden also heute ein bisschen was zum Thema Internet lernen.
Was sind Umsteiger von BTX, Leute?
Kennt ihr noch BTX?
Jetzt kommt wieder Opa Max erzählen vom Krieg.
Telekom, BTX.
Sehe ein bisschen aus wie Videotext.
Sehe ein bisschen...
Ja, so sah das auch.
Sehe ein bisschen aus wie Videotext.
Ist aber nicht Videotext.
Ist BTX.
Grausam.
In der PC-Schule Computer im Griff in Berlin-Rudo
sind die Internetkurse für Anfänger mehr als gut besucht.
Das ist also der DSL-Splitter, der wird in ihrer Telefon-
Damals waren die Dinger noch schön groß, da hat es übrigens noch so eine Handvoll Gerät in der Hand.
Dachte mal, ich habe mir da jetzt überhaupt keine Gedanken mehr drüber gemacht,
weil ich habe schon ewig keinen DSL mehr.
Aber ist der Splitter heutzutage in der Fritzbox mit drin, oder muss man immer noch einen anschließen?
Das ist bestimmt alles integriert schon, oder?
Du stöpselst einfach nur noch die Fritzbox in deine Dose.
Es gibt keinen Splitter mehr.
Braucht man nicht mehr.
Okay, das heißt, sobald du einen Internetanschluss hast,
Telefon schließt du an die Fritzbox an, das geht dann per IP.
Ja, okay, ja, macht Sinn.
Stimmt, stimmt, warum sollte man mal splittern, wenn es kein Telefon mehr gibt?
Hast du noch nie einen Splitter gesehen?
Hast du jetzt auch nichts verpasst?
Damals hat es halt so die Kombination
immer Splitter vorne,
hier, also
Splitter
ging
in die THE-Dose.
Dann ging es
vom Splitter
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher.
Hier unten ging es dann ans DSL-Modem, gell?
Hier unten ging es dann ans DSL-Modem.
Das war auch noch eine richtig fette Kiste.
Diese alten Telekom-DSL-Modems.
Die waren richtig fett.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht die Dinger.
Ne, ja, das geht in die Richtung
Ne, die ganz alten
Die waren so richtig
Fette Metallkisten
Ne
Ja
Das meine ich
Richtig, richtig fettes Ding hier
Guck mal hier
30 cm lang
Gachi Bass
Richtig fett das Modem
Hier kam das Kabel vom Splitter dran
Das da hat man nie gebraucht
Und hier kam der PC dann dran
Genau und hier vorne kam dann das Telefon dran
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
gab es unterschiedliche Splitter
für Analog
und ISDN.
Oder ging man von hier mit einem Kabel
in den NTBA rein.
Kann mich gar nicht mehr genau
dran erinnern.
Ja und hinter dem NTBA hatte man dann
irgendwie, genau, da hatte ich auch
damals, hatte ich noch für ISDN
eigentlich ein Teledat 2AB
oder so hieß das Ding.
ABUSB oder, ja, das Ding hatte ich damals, das war meine ISDN, Anführungsstrichen ISDN Telefonanlage.
Da hatte man, ja, da hat man auch gesehen hier, guck, erster Kanal belegt, zweiter Kanal belegt, Anrufbeantworter stellst.
Ja und für Anrufbeantworter hier hinten dran, an den analogen Anschlüssen, hatte ich da nochmal ein Elsa MicroLink Office, das ist ein altes 56K Modem, das konnte aber, das hat einen Flash Speicher gehabt von ich glaube sagenhaften 2 MB oder sowas, 4 MB, das war Anrufbeantworter und Faxgerät in einem.
Das konnte Faxe annehmen, quasi während, also, auch wenn dein PC nicht an war.
Fax- und Anrufbeantworter hat das noch gemacht.
Da hatte man wirklich eine riesen Kombination aus Geräten.
Erst den Splitter, dann den NTBA, dann das Tele-Daten, dann das MicroLink Office hinten dran.
Und ich denke da heute immer noch gerne dran.
Ich finde das immer noch coole Technik irgendwo.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber mal den Beitrag.
Ach sonst, wir sind 43 Sekunden drin, ich habe 10 Minuten schon geschwätzt dazu.
Dozent Matthias Krebs nimmt den Seminarbesuchern die Angst vor Routern und Splittern.
Immerhin hatte man schon sowas wie LCD-Bildschirme, aber geht es vor allem um eines.
Von der Werbung her wird mir immer nur Schnelligkeit vermittelt.
Gab es da nicht diese Werbung mit Boris Becker, bin ich schon drin?
Am gravierendsten immer, wer ist schneller? Ob man irgendwo drin ist oder nicht oder wie schnell Daten verarbeitet werden. Das ist das Einzige, was mir eigentlich an Werbung übermittelt wird.
ist ja heute im Prinzip noch immer so.
Erzählen alle irgendwas mit
Geschwindigkeit. Dabei, gerade
zu DSL-Anfangszeiten
gab es ja noch das Thema
wie hieß das?
Interleaving, ne? Mit Fastpath
und sowas, wo dann Ping
künstlich schlecht war durch irgendeine
Fehlerkorrektur, die kein Mensch gebraucht hat.
Die Teilnehmer haben zwar alle einen
PC zu Hause, aber
was das neue, schnelle Internet wirklich kann, ahnt kaum einer.
In Zeiten, in denen www häufig mit weltweites Warten übersetzt werden musste, sind vorbei.
Noch nie war das World Wide Web so schnell wie heute.
Fernsehsendungen, Spiele, Musik und Videos, die Inhalte...
Krasse Videos!
320 mal 240 oder irgendwie sowas.
wisst ihr noch gucken mal gucken wer also oldschool ist und das noch weiß
wisst ihr wieder weit verbreitetste video player von damals hieß
für solche web inhalte ich glaube wenn ich mir das blaue hier unten anguckt ist
er das auch was mit x kann sein dass dann x quicktime
Time, ne? Fängt mit R an.
Wedia Player, ne?
Okay, ihr seid nicht
oldschool. Real Player!
Genau.
Real Player.
Okay, die Webseite gibt es immer noch.
So ein Ding hier.
Real Player.
Damit hast du Sachen abgespielt.
Den ersten Videostream, den ich im Internet geguckt habe,
war, da gab es von den Ärzten ein Konzert bei der Telekom.
Ein Streaming-Only-Konzert.
Ein Konzert, das ging irgendwie 45 Minuten oder so.
Und das habe ich mir mit einem Kollegen aus der Schule angeguckt.
über wahrscheinlich alles die er noch
und es war ganz grausame Qualität sowohl
sowohl Video als auch Audio welches Jahr ich hab keine Ahnung
keine Ahnung
2000 oder so
2001, 2002, keine Ahnung.
Ich denke nach 2000, glaube ich.
Vermute ich. Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Also, ich kann Internetentwicklung ungefähr an einem Zeitpunkt festmachen,
und zwar vor und nach Half-Life-Release 1998.
Weil ab da habe ich angefangen, auch Sachen wie Onlinespiele und so zu gucken.
Und danach, ein Jahr später, kam CS raus und sowas.
Da kann ich mir so halbwegs ableiten, es war davor und danach.
1998 war Half-Life 1 Release.
Davor hat mich Online-Gaming und so überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Und danach ging es dann los.
Aber wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video.
Yahoo!
Internetanschluss schlechthin. Das Prinzip, die Leitung wird in einem sogenannten Splitter
aufgeteilt in das Signal zum Telefonieren und für den Datenstrom zum P... Pots? War das nicht so
was wie Plain Old Telephone System oder sowas? Pots? Da ist die Endsplitter. Vorteil, der Benutzer ist
während der Computersitzung immer telefonisch erreichbar. Vom Splitter gehen die Daten dann
zu einem Router und weiter zum Rechner.
Router.
Die Möglichkeiten, die DSL bietet,
während ein ISDN-Anschluss links
für den Aufbau einer Seite...
Also, damals ging man ganz
ohne Router ins Internet.
Man hatte direkt das DSL-Modem
am Rechner dran und sein Rechner hatte
eine Public-IP. Das war
Security-technisch die dümmste Idee, die man
haben konnte, damals
mit Windows mit einer Public-IP
ins Internet zu gehen.
Und um sich ein bisschen zu schützen, hatte man solche Sachen wie Zone-Alarm.
Falls das noch irgendjemand kennt.
Windows XP, suchen wir mal irgendwie danach.
Ja, genau.
Hier, Zone-Alarm.
Da ist es hier.
Hatte man damals.
Ja, so sah das aus, Alter.
Zone-Alarm.
So ein Unannahmen, ja.
Das war eine echt blöde Idee.
Wenn man mit einem ungepatchten Windows XP ins Internet ist,
hatte man mehr oder weniger instant einen Virus drauf.
Und zwar diesen komischen Virus.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Eines der bekanntesten Sachen überhaupt.
Der per Port 135 oder so,
per irgendeinem Windows-Port,
hat er dich infiziert.
Ich kriege es nicht mehr zusammen.
Es hat wirklich nur 1-2 Minuten gedauert.
Wenn du ein frisch installiertes Windows XP ins Internet wolltest,
hattest du gleich ein Virus drauf.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das Ding hieß.
Da musstest du dir quasi eine...
Nein, nein, nicht Love Me.
Nein, nein, nein, irgendwas für Windows XP-Zeiten.
Und da musstest du dir damals quasi eine eigene CD brennen
mit Windows-Patches drauf und Soundalarm und allem,
dass du überhaupt ins Internet konntest, ohne dass
du ein Virus direkt bekommst, damit du
weitere Updates installieren kannst. Blaster!
Blaster war das, glaube ich, an Windows.
Blaster klingt gut.
Blaster. Jaja, Blaster kommt mir
bekannt vor.
Ja! Das ist das Ding!
Blaster!
Genau!
das kam dann immer, das hattest du instant am Start, das hattest du instant am Start, wenn du mit einem ungepatchten Windows XP online gegangen bist,
musstest dir dann eine eigene CD machen mit Service Packs drauf und USB Sticks waren da aber noch nicht so verbreitet,
hat man eine eigene CD gebrannt mit Service Packs drauf
und
Zone Alarm und Antivirus
damals hatte man Free
Avira hatte man damals
ich glaube die meistverbreitetste Kombination
damals war Zone Alarm
für Firewall und Avira für Antivirus
hat es was gebracht?
ein bisschen
man hat sich trotzdem
recht easy immer noch was eingefangen
so weiter geht's
... rund 13 Sekunden benötigt, hat die SL dieselbe Seite in gerade mal 0,9 Sekunden auf dem Bildschirm.
Noch deutlicher ist der Unterschied bei sogenannten Videostreams.
Oben mit ISDN stoppt der Filmtrailer bereits nach wenigen Momenten.
Über DSL läuft er flüssig und ohne...
Die Auflösung war gar nicht mal so schlecht, oder?
Ich meine, das war ja damals noch alles in PAL-Auflösung.
So...
Geht voll klar.
... Unterbrechungen durch.
Doch nicht nur Unterhaltung im Internet wird durch die neuen Geschwindigkeiten noch attraktiver.
Dazu muss Battlefield 6 erstmal erscheinen.
Die echte Heizung.
Wie dem Fußballmanager Michael Preetz vom Bundesligisten Hertha BSC hat der Highspeed-Zugang neue berufliche Möglichkeiten eröffnet.
Gut, wir holen natürlich tägliche aktuelle Informationen über unsere Mannschaft, über
unseren Verein aus dem Internet und wir beschäftigen uns natürlich in erster Linie mit Spielern,
mit eigenen Spielern, aber vor allen Dingen natürlich auch...
Wie stalken die ihre Spieler online?
Ach, das ist der Fanclub.
Ach so.
Mit Spielern, die wir auf dem Markt beobachten.
Das, was unter dem Oberbegriff Scouting läuft.
Und da holen wir die wesentlichen Informationen aus dem Internet.
Was muss im Dezember für den Urlaub sein für jemanden wie Sie?
Es muss einfach zu bedienen sein und es muss natürlich sehr, sehr schnell sein.
Und das alles ist mit dem DSL-Anschluss gegeben.
Hat die Telekom damals was gesponsert bei denen?
Der ehemalige Nationalspieler hat auch die Scheu vor technischem Zubehör verloren.
Ja, ich kann es vielleicht gleich mal zeigen. Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach. Wir brauchen eigentlich nur so eine Starterbox.
Der hat doch, oder Arcor, die hatten doch da einen Sponsor damals, sonst zeigt der doch nicht sowas.
Dann natürlich das obligatorische Stromkabel, den Telefonanschluss und den Modemanschluss.
Also das sind gerade mal drei Kabel, die man stecken muss. Und dann ist man auch schon verbunden.
dann müssen wir halt nur noch
ne so einfach ist es nicht
du musstest ja dann noch
an deinem Rechner musstest ja noch
Zugangsdaten und
Gedöns einrichten
du musstest damals
einen PPOE Treiber
installieren
und dann musstest du
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das mit dem Einwählen
dann funktioniert hat
wahrscheinlich auch über DFÜ
musste man das noch machen
hier
musste man da irgendwie sein
ja genau, sowas hier.
Das hat man dann gebraucht, da muss man seinen Benutzernamen
Kennwort und so eintragen.
Das ging dann über PPoE
zum Modem.
Das war in der Tat
gar nicht so einfach.
Für unbedarfte User.
Die eigentliche Verbindung herstellen
und das sieht man glaube ich dann auch ganz gut.
Die waren Sponsor, ja kein Wunder, dass er das zeigt.
Sehr, sehr schnell funktioniert, wenn wir hier mal auf den Button klicken, sind wir ruckzuck im Internet eingeloggt.
Also das ist schon eine wesentliche Erleichterung.
Doch nicht immer ist das mit der Technik so einfach. Und damit verdient der Mann vor dieser Tür sein Geld.
Schönen guten Tag Frau Schulze.
Oh ne!
Die hatte ich auch letztens vor der Tür stehen.
Die wollten mir erzählen, dass es angeblich bei uns bald Glasfaser gibt und ob wir nicht schon was abschließen wollen.
und
naja, ich habe mit denen nicht weiter
geredet, ich habe die dann nur gefragt
kann ich doch mal im Internet nachgucken
ob ein Glasfaserausbau bei uns geplant ist
und die haben gesagt, ja können sie machen
natürlich ist bei uns kein Glasfaserausbau geplant
war ja doch von Calle PC
sie hatten angerufen bei einem DSL-Anschluss
ach ne, ok, sorry, vergiss
das Blödsinn was ich erzählt habe, ich dachte das ist ein Vertreter
von der Telekom
Das ist irgendein PC-Bastelladen, der den Leuten hilft, daheim den DSL-Anschluss einzurichten.
Andreas Baldauf rückt dieser Tage häufig zu schwierigen Fällen wie Monika Schulze
aus.
Sie ist DSL-Neukundin und hat am Morgen Post mit der Hardware für den Internetanschluss
bekommen.
Nach dem Auspacken die Ernüchterung.
Dann habe ich gesehen, dass du nicht mal weißt, welches Kabel wo reingehört und wo das hingehört.
Das Schöne damals war schon, die Kabel, diese ganzen, die hatten immer so die Nase an einer anderen Stelle.
Also du konntest...
Also ich glaube, das Einzige, wo du es irgendwie verkacken konntest, war vorne an der TAE-Dose vom Splitter noch.
ist irgendwie das falsche. Aber
der Rest war meistens
halbwegs so verdreh- und vertauschsicher.
Aber du konntest auf jeden Fall
immer noch was falsch anschließen.
Und auch wenn ich mir den PC angucke, weil es ja auch nicht bloß da hinten reingesteckt wird.
Bedienungsanleitungen sind hier dabei,
sehe ich. Haben Sie da mal reingeguckt?
Ja, klar. Und?
Achso, ich dachte, das fragt
der Techniker. Weil der Techniker wäre blöd,
wenn er das fragt. Der will Ihnen doch was verkaufen.
Ich dachte, wenn ich es
sowieso nicht hinkriege, rufe ich immer lieber jemanden an,
der mir das macht.
Der Mann von Caller PC benötigt für die Installation nur wenige Minuten und zeigt seiner Kundin sogleich, wie einfach das Anschließen sein kann.
Die Kabel sind idiotensicher gestaltet und passen nur in die für sie vorgesehenen Boxen.
Schon per USB? Voll modern.
Guck mal, das war eine Fritz-Box. Habt ihr es gesehen?
So sahen die Dinger damals aus.
Fritz USB oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, Fritz irgendwas USB.
So sahen die Dinger damals aus.
Ist schon ein langer Weg hinter sich, zu so einer heutigen Fritzbox.
Der Profi-Dealer von 1&1.
Bei der Telekom war das doch so eklig.
Da musstest du dir doch deinen Username irgendwie selbst zusammenbauen für das Login.
Das gab dann irgendwie eine Mitbenutzerkennung, Userkennung, User-ID und Passwort.
Und da musstest du dir irgendwie den Kram selbst zusammenbauen mit einem Rautezeichen dazwischen und sowas.
Das war super weird, Champ.
Also es war nicht irgendwie super easy.
Das war ziemlich kompliziert.
Das ist immer noch so.
Ein Routineeingriff, den sich der Mann vom Servicedienst natürlich bezahlen lässt.
Ja, bezahlen lässt. Damals hat es wahrscheinlich 40 Euro gekostet oder so. Heute lachst du dich darüber. Oder wenig, 20 Euro oder so.
Das geht bei uns ab 28 Euro pro Stunde los.
Keck, wait.
Das werden wir auch hier in dem Fall ansetzen. Da müssen wir nicht den höheren Tarif wählen. Das ist jetzt einfach die normale Installation, einmal DSL und das geht dann weiter zur Netzwerkinstallation etc. Es kann dann schon mal bis zu 54 Euro pro Stunde gehen, aber das ist eher der Ausnahmefall.
Aber Surfen mit DSL-Antrieb hat seinen Preis. Über 20 sogenannte Provider bieten den Breitbandzugang.
Das hat er eigentlich geschickt gemacht, oder?
Der erzählt jetzt groß, dass es auch viel teurer sein kann.
Da fühlt sie sich jetzt richtig gut, dass sie das billiger gekriegt hat.
Auch wenn die das für andere wahrscheinlich nie abrechnen.
... ins Netz an.
Wer sich dafür entscheidet, sollte sich zunächst einen Überblick über die Kosten verschaffen.
Neben der obligatorischen Telefongrundgebühr sind das die monatliche Bereitstellungsgebühr für das DSL
und der jeweilige Monatstarif für den Provider.
Der Paketpreis liegt in der Regel zwischen 30 und 60 Euro.
Hinzu hat sich nichts getan, großartig, kostet heute immer noch.
Nun kommt meist eine einmalige Einrichtungsgebühr als Erstkunde.
Schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, Herr Baldauf.
Andreas Baldauf von Call-a-PC bei seinem nächsten Hausbesuch.
Er ist von einer verzweifelten DSL-Nutzerin angerufen worden.
Die Leitung sei tot, klagte sie am Telefon.
Der Grund für den Ausfall ist diesmal aber nur...
Guck mal, wie viele Geräte man damals da noch am Start hatte, ey.
Nur ein Wackelkontakt in den Datenkabeln. Kein Einzelfall.
Zweitgrößter Provider Deutschlands ist die Firma 1&1.
Die Schaltzentrale des Unternehmens im pfälzischen Montabaur ist eine Hightech-Festung hinter Brandschutzmauern und Sicherheitsglas.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie mag ich die Technik aus dieser Zeit.
Das ist bestimmt Nostalgie dabei.
aber das hatte noch so
Technik in der damaligen Zeit hatte so was
mystisches irgendwie noch
und vor allem hatte die viele
Status-LEDs
man hat es richtig gut gefühlt, wenn dann
auf der Telefonanlage
das Licht für B-Kanal
1 wird benutzt, angegangen ist
beim Telefonieren und sowas
vollkommen
ja gut, selbsterklärend war das nicht
1&1 Rechenzentrum unter der Erde. Wie Sie sehen, ist es nicht so einfach hier reinzukommen.
Und überall sind Kameras, wo man sie beobachtet jetzt die ganze Zeit.
Und was Sie hier sehen, diese blauen Türen, hinter diesen Türen verbergen sich ungefähr 22.000 Server.
Ich zeige Ihnen jetzt mal einen Raum.
Vollgestopft mit modernster Elektronik.
Den hohen Preis für DSL-Anschlüsse erklärt Vorstandssprecher Andreas Gauger mit diversen Zusatzleistungen, die der Kunde bekommt, ob er sie will oder nicht.
Bei 1&1 bieten wir einige sehr spannende Extraservices, dafür haben wir auch hier dieses tolle Rechenzentrum gebaut.
Wir machen Ihnen einen Virenschutz für Ihre E-Mail, Sie bekommen Möglichkeiten einen Anrufbeantworter im Internet zu haben, eine eigene Homepage.
Ja, aber das ist im Prinzip so wie heute auch noch.
Vendor-Login-Versuch.
Dein eigenes Domain ist bei uns alles schon inklusive und das betreiben wir hier aus diesem Rechenzentrum heraus.
Der Anwender kann in Deutschland aus mehr als 140 verschiedenen DSL-Tarifen auswählen.
Ein wahrer Dschungel.
Boah!
So viel gibt's heute... Also Tarife insgesamt.
Aber so viel haben wir heute wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Let's trade bestel.
Auch damals schon.
Tiskali.
Trotzdem habe ich das nicht.
So Arthur Kessin vom DSL-Team, dass für Normal-User nicht auch ein ISDN-Anschluss ausreichend sein kann.
Also zunächst einmal muss jeder Kunde für sich entscheiden, wie viel Zeit er ungefähr im Internet verbringt.
Denn wenn man unter 20 Stunden pro Monat unterwegs ist, lohnt sich die Anschaffung des DSL-Anschlusses eher weniger.
Eine zweite Gruppe umfasst User, die sich im Netz gelegentlich Musik anhören, Videos anschauen oder längere Zeit surfen wollen.
Für solche Nutzer empfiehlt sich ein sogenannter Volumentarif.
Eine zeitliche Beschränkung gibt es nicht, jedoch darf nur eine bestimmte Menge an Daten mit dem World Wide Web ausgetauscht werden und das zum Festpreis.
Ein Gigabyte reicht aber für bis zu 30.000 Internetseiten.
Laikos, meine Güte.
Das sind die mit dem Hund.
Mit diesem gefleckten Hund.
Eikos?
Oh, war das ein schwarzer Hund?
Irgendwie dachte ich,
das ist ein gefleckter Hund.
Siehst du mal, was man im Kopf alles so haben kann,
was gar nicht stimmt.
Schwarzer Hund war es.
Eikos?
Empfehlenswert sind hier
Freenet 1&1 oder Leikos.
Moment!
Der lädt sich sicherlich nur Linux-Distributionen runter hier.
Als nächstes zeigen sie noch einen Napster, hä?
Ja, nur legit.
Das heißt, rund um die Uhr online zum Fixpreis.
Alice war beste. Alice war Hansenet, oder?
Hatte ich auch. Hatte ich damals auch. Alice. Hansenet.
Zeitliche Beschränkung gibt es nicht. Und die Menge der transferierten Daten spielt auch keine Rolle.
Günstige Flatrates haben T-Online, 1&1 sowie die Firma Apoa.
Doch Vorsicht! Einige Provider mieten von der Telekom gleich die gesamte Telefonleitung mit.
Das bedeutet, dass die Dienste von Billig-Telefonanbietern, zum Beispiel für Ferngespräche, nicht mehr funktionieren.
Hm, tja.
Sannig.
Nice.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ja, da kann ich...
1&1 auch.
1&1 hat ja damals die Leute angeschrieben,
so nach dem Motto,
seien wir mal ehrlich, das lohnt sich nicht.
Haben die sogar noch Geld geboten,
wenn die jetzt kündigen.
Also von der Telekom weiß ich es nicht.
Von 1&1 kann ich mich auch dran erinnern.
Hä?
Das war irgendwie eine coole Zeit, so von der Technik her.
Ich meine, ich würde es heute nicht unbedingt haben wollen, wenn ich ehrlich bin, wieder.
Ja, also so ist es nicht.
Aber es war schon irgendwie eine coole Sache.
Gibt es neue Package-Updates?
Wie, nicht?
Wir haben schon eine halbe Stunde her, wo wir Package-Updates gemacht haben.
Warum gibt es da keine neuen?
Was ist aus Arch geworden?
Also ich hatte damals eine Flatrate.
Das weiß ich noch.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
In der Zeit vor DSL.
Da gab es bei der Telekom.
hast du Samstag und Sonntag oder nur Sonntag, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau,
hast du keine Telefongebühren bezahlen müssen.
Das heißt, du musstest nur die Internetnutzung bezahlen,
nicht die Telefongebühren, um dich dahin zu verbinden.
Und da habe ich am Wochenende immer ISDN-Kanalbündelung
Napster gesaugt.
Nee, habe ich mir noch nicht angesehen.
Habe ich auch keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Ich habe meine eigene Arch-Config
und brauche ich keine
andere fertige
Arch-Config.
Auch wenn es von dem Ruby on Rails Erfinder ist.
Brauche ich nicht.
Sie haben Post.
Naja, aber die Zeit war schon cool.
ich habe damals der händering versucht fastpass zu kriegen für dsl wollte die
telekom aber dann erst mal nicht wegen was auch immer ich weiß es gar nicht
warum nicht haben sich gewehrt dagegen wollte das halt unbedingt haben dass ich
ordentlich cs spielen konnte online mit besserem ping weil mit der es mit mit
Fastpass hat es halt immer so ein Ping, so
sagen wir mal so, so
um
zwischen 70 und 100,
120 oder so.
Und ohne Fastpass,
und mit Fastpass hat es halt einen Ping von
5 oder 15
oder so, je nachdem wo der Server stand.
Bei NextNap
sag ich natürlich, ich habe auch
damals nur Linux-ISOs geladen.
Wie wir alle wahrscheinlich
Nur Linux-ISOs
Wir laden auch heute alle nur Linux-ISOs
Du hast CS mit 200 Ping gespielt
Ich auch
Wie kommt man bloß in dieses Internet
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an
Aber
Weil nochmal eine halbe Stunde, da bin ich ja sonst wie am labern
Okay, was haben wir denn hier
20 kreative Home Automations
Was ist das
KZer
Oder Casetta?
Casetta eher.
Komm, gucken wir uns an.
Die machen immer ganz gute Videos.
das ist meine spiele sammeln wenn ich so 1 aus stecken und stecken und sagt läuft hier das brand
guck mal hier das ist meine spiele sammlung ich so 1 aus stecke den usb stick rein und sagt läuft
hier das brandneue von usb das geht um es auch mit sd karten oder ganz wild von sata ssds und
Und der Rechner verhält sich wirklich komplett wie...
Was ist der Reiz da dran?
Anstatt das über Steam zu spielen,
dass man quasi einen Datenträger hat mit Logo und sowas drauf.
Eine alte Spielkonsole.
Keine Systemupdates, keine Patches,
keine Verbindung zum Internet
und der PC bootet in wenigen Sekunden.
Und Abspeichern und Savegames und so
geht natürlich auch ganz normal.
Wenn ihr jetzt denkt, wow, nice...
Alter, das sind die Billig-USB-Sticks, Leute.
Erkennt ihr ihn?
Dann erkennt ihr auch den USB-Stick.
Jeder von uns hatte schon mal diesen USB-Stick.
Das ist, wenn du bei Amazon suchst.
USB-Stick, 20er Pack.
Da ist er.
Das vor allem sind die Dinger...
Ich hab ja auch so ein 20er Pack mal gekauft.
Die Dinger waren so schlecht, Alter.
So schlecht.
Das will ich haben.
Dann ist dieses Video für euch.
Wenn ihr denkt, hä, was soll denn das?
Was soll denn das bringen? Dann auch.
Ich erklär euch nämlich hier auf, warum
physische Datenträger gerade wieder total im Kommen sind.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Erkern, liebe Internet-Server, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Ja, hier im Video geht es ja auch um Linux und ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass KI-Sprachmodelle sehr gut helfen beim Linux-Troubleshooting.
Ja, und der Sponsor unseres Videos...
Egal, wir gucken uns die Werbung an.
aus Frankreich, bietet etliche KI-Modelle
an mit einem einzigen Abo.
Ihr könnt also hier einfach euren Prompt eingeben
und dann zwischen Lama, GPT-5,
Clot, Gemini,
Grog, DeepSeek
und Perplexity auswählen.
Zusätzlich habt ihr die Möglichkeit, Bilder generieren
zu lassen, zum Beispiel mit Flux, mit
Journey und Recraft. Und ihr könnt natürlich
auch Momente und Bilder einfach hochladen
und direkt mit den unterschiedlichen
LLMs analysieren lassen.
Den Sprachmodus mit GPT gibt's auch noch
oben drauf und das alles für
10 Euro. Zum Vergleich,
alleine GGPT Plus kostet
über das Doppelte. Ja, wenn ihr das interessant
findet, schaut mal in die Beschreibung,
da gibt es mehr Infos und einen Direktlink
zu. Mammut.
Werbung Ende.
Ja, als ich das Projekt Carzetta gesehen
habe, war ich direkt verliebt.
Und das ging hier irgendwie dem ganzen Team
so. Auch wenn einige von denen jünger
sind als ich und mit Spielen aus der
Cloud aufgewachsen sind, also
nicht mit physischen Datenträgern,
Aber das Gefühl, einfach eine Spielekassette irgendwo reinzustecken und sofort loszocken zu können,
da scheint universell sehr cozy, hücke, gemütlich rüberzukommen.
Denn wir kennen ja diesen Online-Nerv zu Genüge.
Habt ihr mal ein aktuelles Call of Duty länger nicht gespielt und wollt immer kurz...
Sagt mir nix.
Sagt mir gar nix, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ja, das kann wirklich Stunden dauern, bis alle Updates...
Ja gut, ich wollte gerade sagen, die Dinger sind ja mittlerweile Gigabytes an Daten.
Und ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum die so groß sind, ehrlich gesagt.
Und ich übertreibe nicht, die aktuellen Call of Duty sind nämlich über 150 Gigabyte groß.
Außerdem kann das Gefrickeln mit Launchern und Logins bei PC Gaming definitiv Leute abschrecken, die nicht so technikaffin sind.
Nicht umsonst sind ja sowas wie, keine Ahnung, Tony-Boxen bei Kindern und Hörbärt-Boxen für Senioren beliebt.
Also so maximal vereinfacht...
Hörbärt?
Hab ich doch... Wusste ich nicht, dass das existiert.
Dieser Hörbärt verfügt über eine USB-C-Buchse.
Das ist quasi... So was wäre für meinen Opa auch cool gewesen.
Weil der hielte ja von Computer und Sachen nix.
Naja und sogar Nintendo, die ja die hohe Kunst der Cartridge bis zuletzt auch heute noch
zelebrieren, haben angefangen einige Spiele...
Das ganze Vibe-Coding-Gedöns geht mir auch heftig auf den Keks.
Stack Overflow.
Also meine Default-Suche ist auch immer noch Blablabla, Fehler, Stackoverflow.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz benutze ich mittlerweile auch relativ häufig ChatGPT und sowas.
Gestern auch, wo ich mir Java und Springboot angeguckt habe, da haben wir auch öfters mal ChatGPT gefragt.
Und da war es gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber das waren halt auch basic, easy Sachen.
Jetzt gibt es noch SpecCoding.
Ne, das ist mir neu.
Ach, es gibt wahrscheinlich mittlerweile
Sätze, x-beliebiges Wortcoding ein
...in normalen Spieleverpackungen zu verkaufen
Aber drin ist da dann nur ein Code
Zum Download
Ja, das finde ich auch hängen geblieben
Dann kann man das Spiel auch nicht mehr spielen
Und solche Fälle, also quasi verlorene Spiele
Gibt es immer mehr
Und das kommt verständlicherweise ziemlich schlecht an
Bei der Nutzerschaft
Ja, und wie ist das bei Casetta?
Ja, solange man einen Rechner hat, auf dem man das Casetta
grundsystem installieren kann kann man die kassette datenträger spielen das ist von
vornherein auf maximale langlebigkeit ausgelegt und gleichzeitig ist kassette auch aufs maximale
reduziert kassette funktioniert wirklich wie eine alte spielkonsole wenn man den spiel
sehe ich da chrono trigger beste
wirklich wie eine alte spielkonsole wenn man den spiele datenträger vor dem einschalten
einsteckt, dann startet direkt das Spiel
da drauf. Wenn man ohne Datenträger
einschaltet, dann kommt hier
dieser Screen mit ausgegrautem
Play. Hier oben sieht man unter Data
dann alle die gespeicherten Spielstände.
Ja, und so funktioniert auch
das Prinzip. Es wird immer auf dem
Gaming-Rechner selbst gesichert, also
die Safe Games, damit von den
Spiele-Datenträgern möglichst nur
gelesen wird. Dadurch soll die Lebensdauer
erhöht werden. Ja, das sind ja auch die billig-USB-Sticks.
Die sind ja auch nach dreimal Schreiben kaputt.
SD-Karten und USB-Sticks
vor allem durch...
Man muss aber echt sagen, irgendwie so
ein Datenträger mit Logo drauf,
irgendwie hat das was.
Es ist letztendlich irgendwie Spielerei.
Ich seh mich da jetzt nicht, da hauptsächlich
von zu spielen.
Das ist eher so ein...
Was bei den Leuten irgendwie so diesen Sammlerdrang
auslöst, keine Ahnung.
Also ich seh mich das nicht
für mich irgendwie, dass das Steam
ablöst oder so. Da bin ich viel
zu faul für.
... Lebensdauer erhöht werden, weil SD-Karten und USB-Sticks vor allem durch viel Schreiben...
... Toolkit to help...
... Alles AI-Zeug hat...
... Alles Ins... Ah, gut, das ist auch von GitHub.
... Spec-Driven Development...
... Mehr Wörter aneinander rein, please.
What is spec-driven development?
Code has been king.
Who cares?
AI.
Speck-driven.
Ja, für speck-driven development
wäre ich auch eher.
Reines Lesen verursacht dagegen
so gut wie keinen Verschleiß.
Also nur wenn ein Blog jetzt extrem
häufig gelesen wird aber das kommt in der praxis selten vor wenn dann nur einmal das spiel geladen
wird sollte es klappen na ja und die speicherdaten die kann man sich hier unter data halt angucken
das erinnert stark an das user interface der speicherkarten zum beispiel der playstation 1
ich finde das designmäßig auf jeden fall sehr gelungen ich finde auch diese sound effekte total
charmant hört mal blink blink blink wirkt alles schon sehr polished obwohl und das wäre jetzt
direkt mein disclaimer kasette ist stand heute noch sehr sehr früh software deutlich erkennbar
an der null release namen die frage ist für mich auch ob und wie sich das projekt weiterentwickelt
wenn es sich nicht weiterentwickelt ja dann weiß ich nicht wie zukunft sicher das ganze ist man
kann kasette auf jeden fall heute schon nutzen ich habe mit mehreren spielen erfolgreich hinbekommen
aber ja und brauche man dann einen pc der nur dafür da ist oder wie es ist auch noch ein bisschen
fummelig und viele Sachen laufen auch einfach nicht. Dazu komme ich aber später noch mal im Detail. Erstmal zu den erfreulichen Sachen, die mir
erstaunlicherweise viel Spaß gemacht haben, obwohl ich gar nicht so der Basteltyp bin, nämlich das Herstellen der
physischen Daten. Genau, so geht es mir auch. Da schlägt das
Nostalgieherz kurz höher, aber dann wirklich aktiv nutzen. Ich weiß nicht, genau das ist mein Gedanke dazu.
Ja, Chat, genau so.
Wenn ihr wie ich keinen Drucker habt, dann könnt ihr zum Beispiel zu dem Drogeriemarkt mit den zwei Buchstaben gehen.
Die bieten nämlich direkt das Drucken von Aufklebern an.
Also direkt vor Ort haben die so Drucker da stehen und die stanzen das auch direkt.
Man muss da also nicht mit der Schere herum hantieren.
Leider kann man die Größen nicht manuell festlegen, wenn man das direkt im Laden editiert.
Da muss man sich dann halt so Pi mal Daumen die Bilder hier so anordnen.
Ich habe das einfach mit dem USB-Datenträger gemacht, einfach die Bilder drauf, die ich mir vorher ausgesucht habe und dann los.
Das hat bei mir auf jeden Fall ganz gut geklappt.
Das Drucken und Stanzen hat übrigens bei den Druckern in der Filiale in der Hannoverischen Innenstadt pro Bogen weniger als eine Minute gedauert.
Ja und guck mal, das sind meine Cassetta-Cartridges. Das sieht doch ziemlich clean aus, oder?
Das heißt, man muss sich das komplett selbst machen, oder?
Also man kauft sich einen USB-Stick, dann flasht man das da drauf und drückt sich den...
Also das ist nix, wo man irgendwie... So ganz hab ich noch nicht verstanden.
Ich find's gut.
Ihr seht auch, das sind unterschiedliche Datenträger und ihr fragt euch jetzt vielleicht, was nimmt man denn da jetzt am besten bei Cassetta?
Also ich find ganz klar, am besten kommt natürlich das Label auf so einer fetten SATA-SSD zur Geltung.
Und das wirkt auch von der Form...
Ja gut, aber die ist ein bisschen zu groß für einen Gamer.
Ja, das ist immerher so Cartridge-mäßig, fast so NES-mäßig.
Aber das ist natürlich maximal snobbig hier mit solchen teuren SSDs.
Ja, und außerdem, wie willst du das?
Die wenigsten können SATA-Dinger mal schnell an- und abstöpseln.
Da brauchst du irgendwie einen Hotswap-Ding.
Nein, kein Hotswap, aber irgendeinen Rahmen dafür zum Austauschen.
Und der USB-Stick ist schon besser.
... rumzuhantieren.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Karl Lagerfeld, der über 500 iPods hatte.
halt für jedes Album ein eigenes, weil er das so nervig fand, mit in den Menüs da rumzufummeln.
Also eventuell habt ihr ja eine Bezugsquelle für alte SSDs, die man sonst nicht mehr benutzen würde.
Ich hatte ja noch so 120 Gigabyte SSDs, die würde ich mir in keinen Rechner mehr einbauen.
Deshalb habe ich die jetzt hier halt für Kassetta verwendet.
Das Interface habe ich so einen Standard SATA USB-Kabel verwendet.
Ja, aber das ist blöd. Ich weiß nicht.
dann ist mit USB-Stick schon schöner.
Zweite Variante sind SD-Karten.
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht, SATA zu USB.
Das ist auch das, was Casetta offiziell empfiehlt,
weil die sehen halt aus wie so Switch-Cartridges.
Die gibt es zum Beispiel im 10er-Pack für 40 Euro,
allerdings das Stück dann nur mit 8 GB.
Außerdem haben Rechner halt selten direkten SD-Kartenleser eingebaut.
Ja, und mit dem Kartenleser zu arbeiten, das finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen lame,
weil das auch, ja, das fühlt sich dann nicht mehr an wie eine Konsole.
Deshalb habe ich mich jetzt hauptsächlich für die dritte Variante entschieden, nämlich stinknormale USB-Sticks.
Ja, die USB-Sticks, die wir gerade bei Amazon gesehen haben.
USB-Sticks. Da passt zwar nur so ein kleines Label drauf, aber dafür haben die ein besseres Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
10x USB 3.0 mit 64 GB.
Das sind halt die größten Schrott-Sticks ever, ja.
40 Euro habe ich mir hier jetzt gekauft. Das passt, finde ich.
Und außerdem halte ich das für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass ihr sowieso etliche von den Teilen rumliegen habt.
Dann kann man die auch mit Kassetter benutzen, wenn ihr Lust so habt.
Kurzes Update, bestellt euch bitte nicht diese konkreten USB-Sticks.
Ich kann die nicht empfehlen.
Sehr gut, dass das doch mal sagt, die sind einfach Schrott.
Die ließen sich nämlich nur unzuverlässig und sehr langsam beschreiben.
Ja, und zur Aufbewahrung oder Präsentation, ja, da gibt es natürlich solche Höhlen hier,
wo man die Sticks oder die SD-Karten reinstecken kann.
Oder aber man baut sich mit dem 3D-Drucker so eine drehbare Lazy Susan für USB-Sticks.
Fand ich ganz nice.
Haben wir mal versucht.
Ja.
Nicht alles gibt.
Hat doch ganz gut funktioniert.
Ja, und als Spielkonsole habe ich so richtig Overkill-mäßig diesen Rechner hier genommen.
Ein GMK-Tech Noobbox K10.
Kostet so ab 450 Euro.
Weil GMK-Tech hatte mir den zugeschickt.
Und ich hatte bislang noch keine richtige Idee, wie ich das Teil testen will.
Da ist ein Intel i9-13900.
Ordentlich.
Hat HK drin, also richtig was Leistungsfähiges.
Ich finde auf jeden Fall, dass das Teil auch vom Formfaktor ziemlich konsolig aussieht.
Aber es geht wirklich so ziemlich jeder x-beliebige x86-Rechner mit Kassetta.
Aber leider keine ARM-Architektur.
Also Raspis funktionieren explizit nicht mit Kassetta.
Ja, und ich habe bei dem Gimkartec-Rechner hier einfach das...
Ja gut, macht ja auch Sinn, die Spiele wird es ja dafür gar nicht geben.
Kasetta-Image auf einen USB-Stick geworfen.
Hat übrigens mit Ventoy nicht funktioniert.
Das erste Mal, dass Ventoy was nicht installieren wollte.
Ventoy hatte ich ja im vorletzten Video mal empfohlen.
Bei dem Kasetta-Boot-Image habe ich Balena Etcher verwendet und dann klappte das auch.
Naja.
Gab es bei Etcher nicht auch letztens irgendwie sowas, wo Leute gesagt haben, man soll es nicht mehr verwenden?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr warum.
Irgendwas war da.
Ich habe da noch im Hinterkopf.
Aber ich hab's trotzdem immer noch installiert.
Aber da war irgendwas. Ich weiß
nicht mehr, warum.
Dann bootet man
davon und dann fragt Casetta,
soll ich installieren auf dem internen
Datenträger? Da kann man auch sonst nichts einstellen,
sondern entweder Datenträger platt machen oder
nicht. Bitte bedenken, da gibt's auch
kein Dual-Boot oder so, sondern es wird
einfach die komplette Platte platt
gemacht. Also Dual-Boot wäre ja auch total
unlogisch, weil Casetta soll ja
prinzipbedingt aufs Minimum reduziert sein
Und wenn man da jetzt irgendwie Windows mitbooten könnte, dann wäre es ja auch keine Spielkonsole.
Also, fertig installiert.
Dann habe ich hier im UEFI bei dem Rechner noch Fastboot eingestellt.
Und dann bootet das Teil vom Drücken des Einschaltknopfes bis zum Startscreen in 12 Sekunden.
Geht doch klar.
So viel hat die ungefähr, hat die Xbox 360 auch gebraucht, wenn die eingeschaltet hat.
Das ist jetzt also nicht so instant wie alte Konsolen, aber ich finde, das fühlt sich schon einigermaßen konsolig an.
Ja, und guck mal, wie oldschool das aussieht.
Wir haben so einen Röhrenfernseher angeschlossen.
Leider nur mit so einem einfachen 8 Euro HDMI auf Composite Adapter.
Ja, aber wenn man bessere Qualität will von HDMI auf dem Röhrenfernseher.
Gibt es hier Open Source Contributor im Chat?
Ja, gibt es ein paar.
Aber die können sich ja selbst melden.
Ich weiß, dass es ein paar gibt.
Da muss man ziemlich viel Arbeit und Geld reinstecken.
Deswegen ist das jetzt das Beste, was wir hinbekommen haben.
Auf die Schnelle.
Aber die Röhre ist natürlich...
Ne, anstelle von beten lese ich mir lieber den DD-Befehl dreimal durch.
Optional, ne? Also ihr könnt das natürlich auch an euren 4K-OLED anschließen.
Sieht auch cool aus.
Ja, aber wie bereitet man jetzt die Casetta-Cartridges, also die Datenträger vor?
Das geht zur Zeit nur komplett manuell.
Aber der Casetta-Entwickler schreibt in der Dokumentation, dass schon so ein Automatik-Tool dafür in der Entwicklung sei.
Deshalb zeige ich euch jetzt nur kurz, wie man das manuell macht, weil bald soll es ja eh automatisch gehen.
Dann braucht man das ja nicht mehr.
Also Schritt 1.
Ihr müsst den Datenträger zwingend mit dem Linux-Dateisystem Ext4 verwenden.
Ich habe schon gerade gedacht, BTRFS, was ist da los?
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie bescheuert ich das finde, dass man BTRFS nicht BTRFS, sondern ButterFS ausspricht?
Das hat laut dem Entwickler damit zu tun, dass man zum Beispiel mit dem exFAT-Dateisystem
unter Linux keine Berechtigung zum Ausführen von Dateien zuweisen kann.
Also ihr braucht auf jeden Fall Linux, um Kassetter-Datenträger zu machen.
Oder halt zumindest WSL, also das Windows Subsystem für Linux, also der eingebaute
Linux-Körnel in Windows.
Unter macOS müsst ihr Linux auf einer virtuellen Maschine laufen lassen.
Ich als alter Profi-Linuxer, ne stimmt nicht, aber ich benutze ja zur Zeit CacheOS als Hauptbetriebssystem.
Und da habe ich dann einfach mit der KDE Partitionsverwaltung den USB-Stick vorbereitet.
Also einfach reinschieben, dann in den Partitionsmanager die vorhandenen Partitionen löschen und dann auf Neu klicken und dann Ext4.
Ihr solltet dabei berechnen...
Hey, ich bin auch Open Source Contributor.
Hab schon bei Projekten contributet.
Und ich hab sogar selbst Open Source Projekte auf GitHub, die selbstverständlich alle fehlerfrei
funktionieren.
... noch das Häkchen bei jeder Anhage.
Schritt 2 Spielbesorgen.
Ja und da ist wichtig, dass das DRM-frei ist, also ohne Digital Rights Management, also
ohne Kopierschutz.
Gute Chancen habt ihr da bei GOG, also Good Old Games oder GOG aus Polen.
Da gibt's ja nur Spiele ohne DRM.
Dahinter steckt übrigens CD Project.
Das sind die Leute von Witcher und Cyberpunk 2077.
Und innerhalb von GOG habt ihr dann die besten Chancen mit Kassetta,
wenn es von dem Spiel eine echte Linux-Version gibt.
Das seht ihr, wenn ihr hier draufklickt in GOG.
Wenn ihr dann so ein Spiel bei GOG gekauft habt, dann...
Springs.
Dieses Game, ne?
Das seht ihr, wenn ihr hier draufklickt in GOG.
Das hat so einen nicen Soundtrack.
Das ist, glaube ich, sogar noch irgendwie offen hier.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Wollte ich nur mal erwähnen.
Wenn ihr dann so ein Spiel bei GOG gekauft habt, dann habt ihr immer Zugriff auf alle
Betriebssystem-Varianten.
Ihr wollt natürlich die Linux-Variante runterladen.
Da geht ihr also in GOG in eurem Account auf das Spiel und klickt dann System, dann Linux
und dann kann man das hier downloaden.
Meistens ist das eine SH-Datei.
Da geht ihr dann in das Verzeichnis, wo ihr das Ding runtergeladen habt, zum Beispiel
hier im File Manager.
Rechtsklick auf die Datei, Eigenschaften, Rechtsklick auf den Kreuz bei...
ausführung als programm erlauben machen doppelklick ist aber auch so ist aber auch ganz ähnlich und
sonst halt einfach auf der kommandozeile ihr kriegt das also ihr dürft halt nur nicht vergessen
die sh datei ausführbar zu machen schritt 3 spiel auf datenträger kopiert danach geht ihr dahin wo
das spiel installiert wurde standardmäßig ist das hier im persönlichen ordner und bei gog games ich
habe jetzt mal eines meiner oldtime lieblings spiele wie wie wie wie wie genommen das spiel
selbst ist im Game-Ordner.
Die anderen Sachen hier sind
erstmal nicht relevant.
Ja gut, das kriegen wir im Zweifelsfall auch so hin.
Okay.
Also,
ich sehe mich das nicht benutzen, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist wieder Chat vorhin
gesagt also da kickt mal kurz oder nostalgie faktor so mit datenträgern und sowas aber
danach wird es wahrscheinlich ist dann steht es halt rum und sieht cool aus
die richtigen hacker machen ch mod plus x
die richtigen die richtigen hacker machen ch mod 777
wozu irgendwas anderes
Ein digitales Dorf in der deutschen Provinz.
Aha.
Wie darf man sich das denn vorstellen?
Hartop?
Ja, klar.
Aber H-Top ist nicht mehr angesagt.
Hollywood, beste.
Oh ne, habe ich gar nicht mehr inszeniert.
Da nicht.
Was fritzt, boxt hier so?
Powerline, OKS.
B-Top, B-Top ist nice, ja.
Sieht noch viel mehr Hackerman-mäßig aus als H-Top.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich benutze auch lieber Hardtop.
Auch wenn das so ein fast schon Doom-Style-Menü hat.
Ja, das ist eher was, was cool ausschaut, aber nichts bringt.
Ich persönlich bin eher Hardtop-Enjoyer.
Wohin führt das Internet?
Nein, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Oh, an hier.
Ein digitales Dorf.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Kann man da Behördensachen am PC erledigen?
Und muss kein Fax mehr schicken?
Ja.
Schauen wir mal.
Etteln.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass das Dorf
fucking sich umbenannt hat? Die heißen jetzt nicht
mehr so. Die waren es leid, dass
da Leute das Ortsschild klauen
oder
die Touristen da rumnerven.
Fucking heißt
nicht mehr fucking.
Das Dorf
Etteln in Ostwestfalen. 1750 Einwohner.
Sieh laut.
Landwirtschaftlich geprägt. Tradition spielt hier eine große Rolle.
Viele engagieren sich im Musikverein.
Ja, aber viel gibt's da wahrscheinlich auch sonst nicht.
Wenigstens tossfreie Musik.
Nur auf den ersten Blick ein typisch deutsches Dorf.
Etten siegte Ende 2024 bei einem weltweiten Wettbewerb des Ingenieurverbandes für Elektrotechnik IEEE.
Es gewann vor Metropolen wie Hongkong oder Tokio. Zudem ist es das italste Dorf Deutschlands.
Deshalb besuchen es regelmäßig Vertreter anderer Kommunen.
Der Ortsvorsteher erklärt, wie man ohne eigenen Wagen Etten verlässt, wenn der Verkehrsbus mal nicht fährt.
Etwa ins Nachbardorf Dürrenhagen.
Man kann dann auf eine Taste drücken. Ich mache jetzt hier mal Dürrenhagen.
Warum sind denn die Knöpfe so schepp? Habt ihr das gesehen?
Und dann erscheint da oben Dürrenhagen. Das ist noch nichts Besonderes.
Das Besondere ist, dass jetzt für 15 Minuten auf unserer Dorf-App erscheint,
es sitzt jemand auf der Mitfahrbank und möchte gerne nach Dürrenhagen mitgenommen werden.
Jeder zweite Einwohner hat diese App auf seinem Mobiltelefon.
Wer eigentlich eine coole Idee keines besitzt, in dem Dorf kennt sich wahrscheinlich eh jeder.
Da kann man sich auch noch trauen, bei fremden Leuten ins Auto einzusteigen.
Das würde ich jetzt hier in Frankfurt nicht unbedingt machen.
Die entsprechende Funktion auf mehreren Stählen im Dorf.
Unsere Dorf App zeigt zum Beispiel An- und Verkäufe.
Das heißt, hier kann man sich darüber informieren, was hat ein Bürger abzugeben oder beziehungsweise was möchte neu erworben werden.
Das heißt, das sind unter anderem die Möglichkeiten.
Wisst ihr, was in Frankfurt mit diesem Ding passieren würde?
Das wäre nach einem Tag Aufstellen kaputt.
Diese Wand.
Voll gesprayt, dran gekackt, dran gepisst.
Hätte Risse drinne.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das ganze Ding umgefahren worden.
Das kannst du hier nicht machen, leider.
Oder auch Einladungen zur gestrigen Veranstaltung. Wir hatten eine Informationsveranstaltung im Bürgerhaus.
Neuigkeiten aus dem Rathaus, was passiert in der Gemeindeverwaltung.
Etteln hat im Internet einen digitalen Zwilling, eine realitätsnahe Kopie der Gemeinde.
Hier findet der User Wetterdaten, die Pegelstände der Bäche, falls Hochwasser droht.
oder eigentlich eine coole Sache, da sieht man mal, was man so machen kann, wenn man denn will.
Container für die Altkleidersammlung, die noch Platz haben.
Um zu vermeiden, dass Kleidungsstücke, Kleidersäcke vor dem Container abgestellt werden, da er überfüllt ist,
haben wir einfach einen Sensor im Dachbereich angebracht, das heißt der Füllstand wird registriert.
Das sind ja auch im Prinzip jetzt kein Hexenwerk, ne?
Das ist jetzt nicht super kompliziert, du musst das halt machen.
Digital abgerufen werden kann auch ein E-Auto. Kostenlos. Voraussetzung, sie leben wie die 75-jährige Cicilie Clark in Etteln.
Wir haben eine Frühstücksgruppe in der Straße, damit fahren wir ab und zu. Es wird für Fußballspieler, für die Kinder genutzt.
Und privat natürlich auch. Wenn der Erstwagen der Familie unterwegs ist und man muss dringend irgendwo hin, ja, da nimmt man sich, wenn es da ist, das Auto.
Wenn man es früh genug weiß, bucht man es in den Vorhinein. Das geht alles online, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Unterwegs zum Dorf.
In Frankfurt hätte das Auto auch schon einfach jemand geklaut.
Die Einwohner haben vor Jahren entschieden, jeder auch noch so abgelegene Hof soll schnelles Internet bekommen.
Um Geld zu sparen, legten die Bewohner selbst Hand an.
Sie arbeiteten 3500 Stunden ehrenamtlich, platzierten 30 Kilometer Glasfaser.
Das ist cool.
Die Hauptarbeit besteht darin.
Ich finde es ja cool, dass sie auch alle mitmachen.
Bei uns ist es eher so in der Ecke, dass dann der Opa sagt, ach, wer braucht denn schon Internet und sowas.
Nee, nee, bei mir kommt das nicht hin in die Hütte.
Wie, und ich soll hier bezahlen, dass die Straße aufgemacht wird? Nee, nee.
die Leerrohre zu verlegen, in die dann die Glasfaser eingeblasen wird.
Auch in der Landwirtschaft wird der Breitbandanschluss genutzt.
Einige Bauern kontrollieren die Fütterung ihrer Tiere über Videokameras.
Anderen hilft das schnelle Internet bei Büroarbeiten.
In seinen Hallen repariert der 42-jährige Stefan Mayer Traktoren und andere landwirtschaftliche Geräte.
Der Glasfaseranschluss erleichtert seine Arbeit.
Wir haben davon profitiert, da wir jetzt hier online Ersatzteile für unsere Maschinen bestellen können.
Und auch da wir mehrere Einbrüche hier in der Maschinenhalle hatten, haben wir ein Sicherheitskonzept mit Kamera.
Passiert da also auch?
Was installiert?
Seitdem überall Kameras stehen, hat es auf seinem Hof keine Einbrüche mehr gegeben.
Etteln produziert 34 Mal mehr Strom, als es selbst verbraucht.
Ökostrom aus Biogas, Solar und Windenergie.
Der Batteriespeicher im Dorf. Immer genügend Strom.
Für den die Einwohner ein Drittel weniger zahlen als in anderen Teilen Deutschlands.
Einige Landwirte haben Flächen für Windräder zur Verfügung gestellt.
Die Ettelner denken praktisch.
Auch bei der Wahl des Ortes, wo ihre Server stehen.
Unsere Digitalisierungsplattform wird in einem Rechenzentrum im Windrad gehostet.
Im Windrad? Ja gut, Platz ist da ja schon drin, aber halt eher vertikal als horizontal.
Da direkt dort, wo quasi der Strom entsteht.
Die Dorfgemeinschaft hält zusammen. Der Grund, weshalb es hier bei der...
So, das ist das gesamte Dorf, hä?
...Digitalisierung klappt. Mit Ulrich Ahle an der Spitze.
Der 62-jährige frühere Manager bei der Firma Nixdorf und IT-Profi bespricht regelmäßig mit den Einwohnern die nächsten Projekte.
Eine Drohne für die Feuerwehr oder Videosprechstunden beim örtlichen Hausarzt.
Die Bewohner des Dorfes treiben die Modernisierung voran.
Die machen halt auch mit, das ist ja auch das Gute.
Bei uns hätte es jetzt schon den fünften Aufstand gegeben wegen irgendeinem Windrad oder so.
Dieses Projekt hat ein solches Gemeinschaftsgefühl entwickelt.
Es hat wirklich Spaß gemacht, gemeinsam etwas zu schaffen.
und diese Bereitschaft, die wir auch in Annalo...
Ja, kaum junge Leute, das stimmt, aber es ist auch cool, dass die Alten mitmachen.
...Projekten haben, die haben wir, glaube ich, ganz gut in die digitale Welt auch überführen können.
Bei der Digitalisierung ist es wie bei der Blasmusik.
Wenn viele mitspielen, ist vieles möglich.
Ja, wenn man will geht's.
So viel verdient ein Berufsberater.
Boah ne Alter.
Hör mal bloß auf.
Das war so ziemlich das Sinnloseste, was ich je gemacht hab.
Ein Tag als Fachinformatikerin für Systemintegration.
Ach, 15 Minuten ist zu lang.
Chatge...
Ich krieg langsam echt Hunger.
Moin Soldat.
Nudel mit Lachszeit.
Ich glaube, es gibt heute gar kein Nudel mit Lachs.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch keine Bolognese.
Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht, was es gibt.
Also Nudel mit Lachs weiß ich, dass es die heute nicht gibt.
Weil Nudel mit Lachs gibt es immer sonntags quasi die Reste.
Das heißt, es hätten in einem der letzten Tage schon Nudel mit Lachs geben müssen.
und gab es nicht ich gehe mal doch ich glaube ich weiß was es gibt es gibt auf
jeden fall wahrscheinlich nudeln nudeln mit currysoße oder so dabei glaube ich
gibt es gibt es noch aber keine keine nudeln mit lachs aber mittelzeit haben
wir noch haben wir noch so irgendwas was wir uns angucken können
db lässt offenbar gezielt züge ausfallen über die deutsche überrascht das wirklich irgendjemand
dass wenn diese wenn die züge zu viel verspätung haben dass die einfach nicht
mehr die letzten stationen anfahren ist doch jetzt nichts neues
Also mich wundert das jetzt nicht, also egal, gucken wir mal kurz.
Die Bahn lässt nach Spiegelinformationen offenbar Züge ausfallen.
Die tun so, als wäre das was Neues?
Das weiß man doch seit Jahren schon.
Um die Statistik zu verbessern, demnach werden Fahrten...
Die Logik bei der Bahn ist, ein Zug, der gar nicht kommt, ist auch nicht verspätet.
Das ist ja wirklich die Logik dahinter.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es rechenmäßig nicht bessere Möglichkeiten gäbe.
Man könnte zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ein Zug, der ausfällt, der hat halt so viel Verspätung,
bis der nächste Zug, der die gleiche Strecke befährt, da ist.
Könnte man sagen. Wäre eigentlich relativ easy.
Dann hätte halt manche Züge zwei Stunden Verspätung, weil der nächste Zug erst in zwei Stunden kommt. Aber es ist ja dann für die Leute, die dort am Bahnhof stehen, auch faktisch so.
Ja, die David-Kriesel-Vorträge, die waren nice. Weiß gar nicht, ob es von dem irgendwas Neues gibt.
... mit großer Verspätung vorzeitig beendet und Reisende gebeten, andere Verkehrsmittel zu benutzen.
...
Das juckt mich nicht.
Ich dachte...
Europas Weg aus der Microsoft Cloud.
Das wäre sicherlich nicht verkehrt,
aber irgendwie habe ich meine Zweifel,
dass da...
Das muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Irgendwie habe ich da meine Zweifel, dass sie da was auf die Reihe kriegen werden.
Deutschland-Ticket bald 63 Euro.
Ist das jetzt raus, ja?
Haben sie das jetzt beschlossen oder wie?
Preis steigt wegen Finanzstreit.
Naja.
63 Euro monatlich ab.
Wisst ihr was? Mich stört das gar nicht so sehr, dass das teurer wird. Ein Monatsticket früher hat sogar noch mehr gekostet. Für mich ist der große Vorteil am Deutschlandticket, dass es diesen ganzen Verkehrsverbund-Shit nicht mehr braucht.
Ich habe euch ja schon mal die Story erzählt, wo wir das erste Mal in Köln zur Gamescom gefahren sind.
Da bin ich an Automat und habe mir ein Ticket für die Woche geholt.
Am Hauptbahnhof, in Köln am Hauptbahnhof.
Bin ich an Automat, habe mir ein Wochenticket geholt.
So, bezahlt am Automat, Ticket kommt raus.
Und auf diesem Ticket, was ich schon bezahlt habe, stand drauf, nur gültig mit, ich weiß es nicht, Kölner Verkehrsverbunds Nummer.
Da habe ich gedacht, was?
Was wollen die von mir? Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich da eintragen soll.
Außerdem habe ich das schon bezahlt.
Was wollt ihr denn jetzt von mir überhaupt?
und
dann bin ich damit in den Bus
und hab den Busfahrer gefragt
oder ich weiß nicht, wir waren glaube ich sogar in diesem
in diesem Büro dort und die wussten
das nicht und der Busfahrer hat auch gesagt
einfach ignorieren
und man sich dann auch
fragt, hä? Hat da einer
die falschen Ticketvorlagen reingemacht
oder wie?
Verstehst du nicht, ja?
Steht drauf, nicht gültig
ohne und jeder sagt ja ignorieren sie das über die app kaufen ging auch nicht
weil über die app ging nur mit post ident und als weiß ich also ganz ehrlich
diese ganze verkehrsverbund schritt es ist froh es ist es ist gut und ich bin
froh dass es den nicht mehr gibt also gibt es ja noch aber mit dem
deutschlandticket muss es dich nicht mehr interessieren wo die auf jeden fall
aufpassen sollten ist das nicht aus dem deutschlandticket wieder einzelne
Kreise aussteigen und das
fragmentiert wird. Weil das kann es nicht sein,
da hast du ein Deutschland-Ticket, musst aber trotzdem drauf gucken,
ob das die Strecke, die du fahren willst, auch gilt.
Das sollte wirklich nicht sein.
Ich sehe das irgendwie schon kommen,
weil wir in Deutschland einen Hang dazu haben,
diese Sachen unglaublich zu
verkomplizieren und unbenutzbar zu machen,
wenn es mal was Gescheites gibt.
Also,
dieser ganze Verkehrsverbund,
den kann es meinetwegen noch geben,
aber dank dem Deutschlandticket muss es dich nicht mehr interessieren.
Was man übrigens machen kann, by the way, man kann sich einen Erste-Klasse-Aufschlag kaufen.
Das gilt dann aber wiederum nur für den jeweiligen Verkehrsverbund.
Also es gibt beim RMV kann man sich ein Deutschlandticket-Aufschlag für die Erste Klasse kaufen.
Der gilt dann allerdings nur im RMV-Gebiet.
Das ist dann auch wieder Weirdchamp.
Mache ich aber nicht, ich fahre mittlerweile so selten.
maximal 1-2 Mal die Woche,
dass sich das für mich
mit dem Aufschlag nicht lohnt.
Ich fahre dann auch zu Zeiten, wo es nicht so ultra voll ist.
Ich fahre ja meistens jetzt schon ein bisschen
früher dann weg in Frankfurt.
Ich mache das,
ich time das meistens so,
dass ich fahre mittwochs hin,
weil mit der Gruppenrunde und Teamrunde
und Projektrunde und alles mögliche
Mittwoch wird nichts gearbeitet,
Mittwoch wird nur gemietet.
Und dann mache ich das so,
ich fahre da morgens hin
dann
wird da gemietet
und dann gucke ich, dass ich so 14.30 Uhr
schon wieder heimfahre
weil 15 Uhr geht das
Gemiete weiter
aber da muss ich nichts machen, da muss ich eigentlich wirklich nur
zuhören, dann nehme ich hier immer mein Headset
mit und laufe dann einfach heim
und miete in der Zwischenzeit noch ein bisschen
so bis 15.30 Uhr
So und dann sind das Zeiten, wo die Züge nicht so voll sind und meistens auch relativ pünktlich noch.
Europa will sich...
Gucken wir mal, wie sie aus der Microsoft Cloud wollen.
Ich habe ja meine Zweifel, dass sie überhaupt irgendwas hinkriegen.
Unabhängiger von US-Unternehmen machen, vor allem beim Thema Microsoft Office.
Und wusstet ihr, dass unter dem Namen Next Cloud Workspace, IONOS und...
Ihr wollt nicht wirklich Nextcloud verwenden, oder?
Mon KS, Alter. Please.
Nextcloud gemeinsam schon eine Alternative entwickeln, also einen souveränen Online-Arbeitsplatz mit E-Mail-Auswahl.
Also nennen die das einfach nur Nextcloud oder ist da auch wirklich Nextcloud drunter?
Und Nextcloud ist so ein anstrengendes Stück Software, Alter.
... Konferenzen, Chat und KI, basierend auf Open-Source-Technik.
Das Ding soll komplett europäisch bleiben und der Betrieb soll ausschließlich in Deutschland stattfinden.
Oder hier ein...
Die Bundeswehr steigt gerade auf LibreOffice um. Ja gut, das kann man ja auch benutzen.
Ja, LibreOffice geht ja irgendwie klar.
Ich verstehe eh nicht, wozu man Office-Anwendungen braucht.
Ich benutze keine Office...
Die einzige Office-Anwendung, die ich regelmäßig verwende, ist PowerPoint.
Und das liegt auch zum größten Teil nur daran, weil die bei uns auf der Arbeit halt auf die offiziellen PowerPoint-Vorlagen stehen.
Ja, das muss Corporate Identity Design sein.
Das finden die alle ganz toll.
Wenn das einfach nur ein in Markdown umgewandeltes PDF ist, wo man die Seiten durchklickt, die nicht Corporate Identity aussehen,
da gucken sie immer blöd.
Also im Prinzip ist PowerPoint
deswegen das einzige, was ich finde. Und ich muss sagen,
ich finde PowerPoint auch von der Handhabung und allem
gar nicht so schlecht. PowerPoint geht
klar. Alles andere braucht
man nicht. Wozu braucht man Word
beispielsweise? Unsinnig, überflüssig.
Ja? Wenn ich Text schreiben
will, kann ich es im Texteditor mit Markdown machen.
Wozu braucht man Excel?
Also wozu braucht man, ich
brauche kein Excel. Ich
verstehe, dass Excel die Idee
der sekretärin ist im endeffekt also da viele unternehmen leben ja quasi in
excel aber was was gibt es dann sonst noch visio aller kriegte anfälle was ist
was was gibt es sonst noch in office weiß dass gerade mehr ms project größte
krebs oft wäre überhaupt was sind da sonst noch so drin teams der teams zählt
für mich nicht so richtig zu oft.
Access, MonkaS, Access.
Outlook, ja gut, Outlook kriegt man halt aufgedrückt,
ob man das will oder nicht.
Access, Access ist das Allerschlimmste.
Schauen wir mal, was die hier treiben wollen.
Eine Open-Source-Notion- bzw. Google-Docs-Alternative
mit dem kreativen Namen Docs.
Gemeinsam gefördert von Deutschland, Frankreich und den Niederlanden.
Oder hier das Projekt.
Warum haben die Cute-Baguettes?
Das ist ein cooles Logo.
Das ist eigentlich ein cooles Logo.
Guck mal.
Für Deutschland gibt es eine Brezel.
Für Frankreich gibt es ein Baguette.
Und ein Käse.
Das ist doch wirklich...
Und außerdem sind das auch noch Cute-Brezeln und Baguettes.
Ach ne, die Niederlande sind das mit dem Käse.
Das finde ich ist mal wirklich ein cooles Logo.
Baguette, Käse und Brezel.
Oder hier das Projekt OpenDesk, eine ebenfalls freie und europäische Alternative zu Office 365.
In diesem Video geben wir euch einen Überblick, warum das gerade sinnvoll sein könnte und was da in Europa schon so gekocht wird.
Bleibt dran.
Dass das sinnvoll ist, will ich gar nicht in Abrede stellen.
Ich habe so meine Zweifel, was IT-Projekte angeht,
ob wir das auf die Reihe bekommen.
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ist meine Lautstärke überhaupt richtig?
Volume Mixer?
Input, das macht man nicht bei Volume Mixer.
Ja, wie könnte man auch darauf kommen,
dass man bei Volume Mixer das Volume von dem Mikrofon einstellt?
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Aber ich habe schon wieder das Falsche aufgemacht.
80, nee, ist richtig.
Okay, warum braucht man europäische Alternativen?
Ja, also Europa ist in vielen Bereichen abhängig von US-Unternehmen.
Konzerne wie AWS, Google, Oracle, Broadcom, OpenAI und allen voran Microsoft dominieren auch in Europa viele Bereiche der IT.
Und das auch in Behörden.
Laut dieser Marktanalyse im Auftrag des Bundesinnenministeriums arbeiten 96% aller Behörden in Deutschland mit Microsoft-Produkten.
Also so Sachen wie...
Ja, nicht nur Behörden, das ist bei vielen Unternehmen sicherlich genauso.
...Soft Teams, Word, Excel und so weiter.
Und ja, das sorgt in Europa bei einigen für Bauchschmerzen und das auch nicht erst seit gestern.
Aber warum eigentlich?
Kann ich verstehen.
Ja, also spätestens seit dem 2018 verabschiedeten US-Cloud-Act können US-Behörden ohne vorherige Genehmigung
jederzeit auf personenbezogene Daten in Rechenzentren in Europa und anderen Teilen der Welt zu greifen,
die von US-Unternehmen im Ausland gespeichert werden.
Also kurz gesagt, selbst wenn die Microsoft-Server in einem EU-Land betrieben werden,
könnte die US-Regierung da an die Daten dran, wenn sie das will.
Glücklicherweise war die Aufregung über den Cloud Act erstmal größer als das, was Stand heute passiert ist,
denn das Ding hat bisher eigentlich keine wirkliche Rolle gespielt.
Laut Microsoft gab es Stand 2024 nur 166 Anfragen, nur eine davon betraf einen Kunden außerhalb der USA
Ja gut, nur weil das jetzt der Ist-Stand ist, heißt das ja nicht, dass es so bleibt.
Wer weiß, was sich im Kona-Land da wieder so einfallen lassen wird.
Naja gut, aber jetzt auftritt Trump 2.0.
Und der ist dieses Mal, naja, nicht unbedingt viel besser drauf als in seiner ersten Amtszeit.
Strafzölle und daraus resultierender Handelskonflikt mit der halben Welt,
Entlassung tausender Regierungsmitarbeiter ohne Zustimmung vom Kongress,
Einsatz der Nationalgarde bei minimalen Protesten,
Gut, das wissen wir ja, dass da...
...Romant, Grönland zu annektieren und so weiter.
Ein paar Sachen, die in nur sieben Monaten passiert sind.
Ich glaube, man checkt, warum Europa versucht, sich unabhängiger von den...
Also ich fand, das Beste, was er erzählt hat, war immer noch, dass man zu Corona Desinfektionsmittel trinken kann.
Und da geht es nicht nur um Datenschutz, denn falls die US-Regierung Microsoft mit Anordnung zwingen sollte,
Cloud-Dienste wie 365 einfach abzuschalten, können manche Behörden in Europa von einer Sekunde auf die andere einfach keine Mails mehr schreiben oder chatten.
Also man ist leider einfach erpressbar.
Okay, aber was macht Europa jetzt dagegen?
Fangen wir mal mit Deutschland an.
Was das angeht, benutzen zumindest in Deutschland...
Wir schenken erstmal einen Fax, bevor wir damit anfangen.
Die meisten Behörden noch die On-Premise-Version von Office, also die lokale Version ohne Cloud.
Nur sechs Bundesländer, darunter Bayern und Niedersachsen, nutzen...
Wir schenken erstmal einen Fax, wohin, dort wird es wieder abgetippt und weitergeschickt.
...Microsoft Public Cloud Dienst.
Erinnern ihr euch noch dran? Das ist ja nicht ausgedacht.
Das war, als das mit Corona losging, wurden so die Daten verschickt.
Per Fax, der andere hat es wieder abgetippt.
Oder haben es zumindest geplant.
Längerfristig will die Bundesregierung auf eine Cloud der SAP-Tochterfirma Delos setzen.
Die will in ihren Rechenzentren Microsoft...
Ob das so viel besser ist, wenn man sich dann von SAP abhängig macht?
... und weitere Cloud-Dienste exklusiv für deutsche Behörden betreiben.
Und da SAP ein deutscher Konzern ist, haben US-Behörden juristisch...
Aber es ist SAP, Alter.
... sehen erstmal keinen direkten Zugriff, zumindest auf dem Papier.
Und für den Fall, dass Microsoft keine Updates mehr liefert, will das Unternehmen die Cloud zumindest über einige Monate weiter betreiben.
Außerdem finanziert die Bundesregierung seit 2022 das Projekt OpenDesk.
Das ist eine Open-Source-Alternative zum Microsoft 365 und besteht unter anderem aus Nextcloud als Dateimanager,
...
... als Online-Office und dem Instant Messenger Element.
Das Ding wird vom öffentlichen...
Muss es wirklich Nextcloud sein?
... Zendes entwickelt.
Das steht für Zentrum für digitale Souveränität der öffentlichen Verwaltung.
Die Lidl-Cloud?
Die ist immer noch am Start.
Das ist ja nicht Lidl-Cloud, das ist ja...
Wie heißen die?
Gruppe. Irgendwas Gruppe.
Bla bla Gruppe.
Stackit?
die dahinter stecken.
Irgendwas, blaue Gruppe.
Schwarzgruppe, genau.
Ja, das ist es.
Ja, die gibt es immer noch.
Das ist auch, was man so sieht und hört,
eigentlich recht groß mittlerweile
und wächst weiter.
Aber da kenne ich mich nicht sonderlich mit aus.
2022 vom Innenministerium ins Leben gerufen.
Weißt du, dass sie eine hässliche Webseite haben?
Können auch Unternehmen mit der Suite arbeiten.
Die Enterprise-Version kann ein Unternehmen
entweder selbst im eigenen Rechenzentrum hosten oder als Software as a Service beziehen.
Ja, aber OpenDesk hat den Durchbruch leider noch nicht wirklich geschafft.
Im April 2025 lag die Zahl der Nutzer bei ca. 70.000 in allen Bundesländern.
Wenn man bedenkt, dass es bundesweit mehrere Millionen PC-Arbeitsplätze gibt, ist das noch ein bisschen mau.
Dann gibt es noch das Projekt DOCS, an dem Deutschland, Frankreich und die Niederlande beteiligt sind.
DOCS soll eine quelloffene Alternative zu Tools wie Notion oder Google Docs werden.
Ja, also das Ding auch DOCS zu nennen, finde ich suchmaschinentechnisch...
Ja, ist nicht so clever, das stimmt.
Ein bisschen dumm, aber hier auf der GitHub-Seite ist so ein süßes Bild von einem Baguette, einem Gouda und einer Brezel vor einem Laptop.
Das ist doch schon ein bisschen knuffelig, oder?
Also man kann schon festhalten, dass Deutschland einige Leuchtturmprojekte in der Pipeline hat, so richtig eingeschlagen hat davon aber noch nichts.
Die Niederlande. Also in den Niederlanden sieht das mit den Alternativen zu Microsoft nochmal ein bisschen schlechter aus.
Da hat das Innenministerium im Jahr 2022 Regierungsbehörden die Nutzung von Public Cloud Diensten offiziell erlaubt.
Der staatliche IT-Dienstleister SSCICT hat daraufhin einen Vertrag über die Nutzung von...
Gut, gut, dass die alle immer so griffige Namen haben. SSCICT.
...Office 365 geschlossen, sodass die Cloud mittlerweile beinahe von der gesamten Zentralregierung in den Niederlanden benutzt wird.
Naja, aber Den Haag hat mittlerweile angekündigt, dass sie ihre Richtlinien für den Einsatz von Cloud Diensten überarbeiten wollen.
Die Aspekte der digitalen Autonomie und Sicherheit würden in der neuen Politik stärker berücksichtigt.
Ja, dann macht mal.
Ah, und die Niederlande beteiligen sich seit Dezember 2024 auch mit an dem deutsch-französischen Projekt DOCS.
Ja, das ist der Käse.
Übrigens repräsentiert als kleiner Gouda.
Dänemark.
So, Thema Dänemark.
Die dänische Regierung bereitet schon seit einigen Jahren den Wechsel zur Microsoft 365 Cloud vor.
Letztes Jahr hat sogar noch der staatliche...
Wann den Wechsel? Vorne oder den Wechsel? Zu.
IT-Dienstleister Statens IT in einer Datenschutzfolgeabschätzung festgestellt, dass die Nutzung von Cloud-Anwendungen
durch Behörden mit der DSGVO vereinbar ist.
Und Dänemark hat bisher ja auch eigentlich ein sehr enges Verhältnis zu den USA.
Tja, aber spätestens seit Trump offen damit gedroht hat, die Kontrolle über Grönland
auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise zu übernehmen, sind einige in Kopenhagen bestimmt nicht mehr
ganz so sicher, wie diese eigentlich gute Beziehung denn weitergehen soll.
Ja, und da sind wir wieder beim Thema Erpressbarkeit.
Der Vorsitzende des Dänischen Rates für Cybersicherheit und Technikchef der Sicherheitsfirma Dubex bringt es ganz gut auf den Punkt.
Der sagt nämlich, wenn die Amerikaner um 8 Uhr am Montagmorgen entscheiden, US-Cloud-Dienste abzuschalten, dann wird Dänemark um 9 Uhr stillstehen.
Ja, schon beunruhigend, sage ich mal.
Und Dänemark hat auch bisher keinen wirklichen Lösungsansatz, um dieses Horrorszenario zu verhindern.
Die Dänen denken sich einfach, es passiert eh nicht.
Und was wahrscheinlich auch so sein wird.
Ein paar halbgare Floskeln aus dem Digitalministerium wie, es ist niemals erstrebenswert von einzelnen Anbietern abhängig zu sein, gibt es bisher keine konkreten Projekte.
Naja, mal schauen.
Die Schweiz. Auch die Schweiz hatte 2023 beschlossen, Microsoft 365 in der Verwaltung einzuführen.
Damals die Begründung, es gibt keine Alternative, da Microsoft die On-Premise-Produkte
Entra-ID-Chat ist das, das ist Azure Active Directory, ne? Heißt jetzt ja anders.
in Zukunft eh nicht mehr weiterführe.
Mails und Kalenderdaten würden aber weiter
in den Rechenzentren des Bundes gespeichert werden.
Und Beamte dürften auch keine vertraulichen Dokumente
in der Microsoft Cloud speichern.
Bisher sollen so für...
Ja, da musst du dich wieder drauf verlassen,
dass die Leute das richtig machen.
So nach dem Motto, aha, ist das ein vertrauliches Dokument?
Ah, dann muss es dahin. Nein, ist es nicht.
Ah, dann darf es dahin.
Da wird wieder irgendwas...
Das wird nicht klappen.
50% der Arbeitsplätze in der Bundesverwaltung
auf 365 umgestellt worden sein.
Und bis Ende des Jahres soll der Rest folgen.
Also auch mit Trump wird das Vorhaben erstmal nicht abgebrochen. Aber wie Deutschland will die Schweiz mittel- bis langfristig die Abhängigkeit von Microsoft zumindest reduzieren und es sollen Open-Source-Alternativen geprüft werden. So hieß es zumindest 2023. Mittlerweile ist das auch schon ein bisschen konkreter geworden, die Machbarkeitsstudie Büroautomation mit Open-Source.
Ja, bei sowas, das ist ja zwar bei den Schweizern, aber sowas sind wir ja auch immer gut drin.
Wir führen 800 Machbarkeitsstudien durch, bevor mal irgendwas passiert.
Software, kurz.
Ich sag nur, der Meinrad Schnellweg, nee, wie heißt das Ding?
Doch, Meinrad Schnellweg, südlicher Meinrad Schnellweg und nördlicher Meinrad Schnellweg.
Also die Namen schon, ne?
der seit 15 Jahren Machbarkeitsstudien durchgeführt werden.
OS soll bis 2026 die bereits erwähnte Open Desk Suite auf verschiedene Aspekte prüfen.
In der Studie wird aber auch betont, dass nicht geplant ist, Microsoft 365 zu ersetzen,
sondern eher nach einer Notfalllösung geschaut werden soll.
Ja, immerhin.
Österreich. In Österreich ist 300 nach einer Notfalllösung geschaut werden soll.
Österreich. In Österreich ist 365 vor allem im Bildungssektor etabliert.
Das heißt, dass Schulen im ganzen Land seit 2013 den Cloud-Dienst über einen Vertrag des Bildungsministeriums nutzen können.
Auf eine Anfrage zur Nutzung von Microsoft-Produkten oder der Suche nach unabhängigen Alternativen gab es leider keine Antwort.
Aber im Koalitionsvertrag der seit März regierenden Koalition aus ÖVP, SPÖ und NEOS steht,
dass sie sich vorgenommen haben, in Abstimmung mit europäischen Partnern verstärkt auf Open Source zu setzen
und digitale Souveränität bei Beschaffung zu berücksichtigen.
Konkrete Maßnahmen werden dabei aber nicht genannt.
Ach, Österreich hat jetzt auch Trusted Flaggers.
Frankreich.
Frankreich wollte zwar auf Anfrage auch keine Details raushauen,
hat aber schon seit 2021 relativ strenge Regeln für die Nutzung von Cloud-Diensten.
Die sagen, dass Daten von französischen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und Unternehmen
nur mit Diensten verarbeitet werden dürfen, die immun gegen Nicht-EU-Gesetze sind
und bestimmte Cybersicherheitsanforderungen erfüllen.
Microsoft 365 erfüllt das nicht, deswegen darf der Cloud-Dienst in französischen Behörden nicht die Regel sein.
Und genau wie Deutschland mit Delos will Frankreich Microsoft Cloud-Dienst...
Darf nicht die Regel sein, das ist ja auch wieder ein bisschen schwammig.
... in speziellen Rechenzentren betreiben, die von einer französischen Firma betrieben werden sollen.
Damit erschwert man US-Behörden den Zugriff.
Das Unternehmen heißt Bleu und arbeitet wie Delos momentan daran, die Einhaltung der staatlichen Sicherheitsanforderungen nachzuweisen.
Und seit der Corona-Pandemie arbeitet Frankreich wie Deutschland an einer Open-Source-Anwendung für Office-Aufgaben.
Die 2021 vorgestellte Suite heißt La Suite Numerique und umfasst Tools für Videokonferenzen, Mail, Messenger und Dateiablage mit integriertem Online-Office.
Der bereits erwähnte Editor Docs gehört übrigens auch dazu.
Ihr erinnert euch, das Baguette hier auf dem kleinen süßen Bild?
Die Suite wird vom öffentlichen Unternehmen Dynum entwickelt.
Das ist sowas wie das deutsche Zendes, nur dass Dynum nicht nur den Auftrag erteilt, sondern selbst Softwareentwickler beschäftigt.
Also so wirklich?
Ja, ich muss sagen, da sind schon einige ambitionierte Projekte dabei, die Europa auf jeden Fall helfen könnten, etwas unabhängiger von US-Unternehmen zu werden.
Aber was Alternatives gibt es nicht so wirklich.
Aber das meiste steckt noch in der Entwicklung und Microsoft-Produkte sind halt leider zu tief in den meisten Behördenstrukturen integriert.
Also bis es da mal zu einer völligen Unabhängigkeit in dem Bereich kommen sollte.
OVH ist in Frankreich? Waren das nicht die, wo das Rechenzentrum abgefackelt ist?
Das wird noch einige Zeit ins Land gehen.
Aber ist trotzdem kein schlechter Anbieter.
Wenn ihr zu dem Thema seid, schreibt es mir gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Ansonsten abonnieren und liken nicht vergessen.
Und bis zum nächsten Mal.
ich gebe es ist vielleicht machen wir nachher weiter mit java progress
habe ich da bock drauf mich damit noch weiter auseinanderzusetzen
und was zu lernen ich werde noch zum java experte hier
ja ich gehe was essen leute wir hören uns macht's gut bis denn